this is jocko podcast number 290 with
echo charles and me
jaco willing good evening echo good
evening
within 24 hours i had ordered the
special operations units to assemble in
north carolina
on the seal side all were senior
enlisted
from the same seal squadron all were
hand-picked by the seal commander
all had extensive combat experience the
aviation crews
were equally experienced and also
hand-picked
but none of them knew why they were
being asked to come to north carolina on
such
short notice the following day
as we ushered the members of the raid
team into the conference room
at our north carolina location i could
see a look of annoyance
on their faces by this time
i had briefed my boss admiral eric olson
on the bin laden mission olson
along with the under secretary of
defense for intelligence mike
vickers and several cia senior officers
were also present in the conference room
the operator's body language was
unmistakable
clearly they thought they had been
dragged out of virginia beach in fort
campbell
to participate in some kind of no notice
exercise
just to impress the brass
i offered some short welcoming remarks
and then turned over the briefing to a
cia officer
he began by handing out non-disclosure
forms
i watched with some amusement as the
body language began to change
rarely were non-disclosure forms
required
for exercises even sensitive ones
it took a few minutes before the forms
were signed and collected
then another cia official stepped up on
the small stage
and began to brief the target the
operators
shifted in their chairs sitting up to
focus
on the slides on the screen the cia
officer began
gentlemen for the past several months
the cia has been tracking
an individual we call the pacer
embedded in the slide was a link the cia
officer clicked on the link and a video
played on the screen
everyone watched as the pacer moved
around the compound at ac
one we have reason to believe
that the pacer is osama bin laden
at the sound of bin laden's name there
was silence in the room
i could see a number of the seals
glancing around at each other
as if to ask are they screwing with us
or is this for real
the briefing went on for another 30
minutes
after the cia analyst finished i pushed
away from my table
stood up and made sure everyone was
clear on why
we were here gentlemen i told them
the president has asked us to develop a
raid option
to capture or kill bin laden
for the past several weeks a small team
has been planning the mission
but now we have to find out whether the
plan is executable
we have less than three weeks to test
and rehearse the plan
at the end of that time i have to report
back to the president
on the viability of the mission
there was no emotion from the operators
no smiles
no acknowledgment of the magnitude of
the operation
now it was all business
i continued the agency has built a
mock-up of the compound
just a mile from here you have two days
to work through the movements on target
after that we will move to another
location out west to do the full
dress rehearsals
i offered the other senior officers an
opportunity to say a few words
but they recognized that this was about
the operators not a time to wax
philosophically about the importance of
the mission
i will turn you over to your boss and
you guys can work out the details
any questions there were none
all right i said let's get to work
and that right there is an excerpt of
the book c stories
which was written by admiral william
mcraven
admiral mcraven served 37
years in the navy and held
just about every position of leadership
there is
from seal platoon commander all the way
up to
four star commander of all united states
special operations forces he oversaw
thousands and thousands of combat
operations around the globe during his
time in service including some of the
most important operations
and perhaps the most important operation
in the history of u.s special operations
the killing of osama bin laden
and all the while even with that
incredible burden of command
admiral mcraven was always connected
with the troops
as an example he stopped by my little
base in baghdad and said hi to this
common platoon commander as we geared up
for a mission
and asked ernest questions about what we
were doing and how we were doing it
and then listened intently as i
explained my little part of the war he
was always present
thoughtful respected balanced
and as good of a representative of the
seal community
as we could have hoped for and
we have the honor of having him
with us here tonight to share his
vast experiences and lessons learned
admiral thank you for joining us
jacqueline great to be with you
that's um that's from the book c stories
now
you've written four books thus far
c stories make your bed your latest one
which was called the hero code
and then spec ops
case studies in special operations
warfare and practice i'll probably spend
some time
uh well i'm going a little bit i'll go
into about into the
yeah we'll go the array of books that
you've written at some point
and see stories is sort of
well you were saying that's about as
close of a memoir as we're going to get
from you that's about it
yep i guess this podcast is going to
have to do that this will do it i'm
going to dive into c
stories first and because it relays some
of your early experiences
um here's the deal i'm gonna just read
little tiny chunks of this book because
you read your own audiobooks which is
awesome so people can go out and buy
those but
in order to maybe trigger us into some
other conversations and some stuff
that's not in the books
i'll set it up and i always like to
start at the beginning
and and find out you know who these
people are
where they came from how they ended up
the way they did and and you got a
pretty good
pretty good interesting background and
with that i'm gonna go to the book here
talk to your dad when i asked him years
later why he joined the military
he said that as a boy he watched
soldiers march through the streets of
his hometown of marston missouri
and board a train bound for the trenches
of france
his father an army surgeon was one of
those men
he knew then that he wanted to be a
soldier after graduating from
aviation officer school at brookfield in
san antonio texas
he re received orders to the 309th
fighter squadron 8th air force the 309th
was part of the first american
contingent to be posted in the united
kingdom
at the time the americans were still
working to build a fighter aircraft
that could complete in aerial combat
against the german messerschmitt
so when dad arrived in england he and
the other pilots of the 309th
were given british spitfires the spits
equipped with a powerful rolls-royce
engines new guns and sleek aerodynamics
were good enough to go toe-to-toe with
the germans
dad flew the spitfire throughout the war
going on to fight
in the campaigns in north africa sicily
salerno
and eventually at the normandy invasion
he registered
two confirmed kills during the war but
would himself be shot down over france
in 1943
the saga of his escape and evasion from
france back to england was told many
times during our posting in france
but not by dad who rarely talked about
his wartime service
but by the french resistance fighter who
helped him back to freedom
and now lived near us on the outskirts
of paris so your dad's a freaking war
hero coming out of the game
well yeah i think they were all heroes
back then i mean you think about this
greatest generation
and i was fortunate growing up as a kid
in san antonio texas that
you know all of my dad's friends even
back then
had served in the air force or the the
army air corps or the army and
and they all fought in world war ii so
you know you experienced these
you kind of remarkable stories from
these guys
but of course that generation both my
both my parents my father and my mother
you know they grow up
uh during the depression uh they grow up
as children of world war one as i
mentioned my dad watched his father go
off to serve in world war one
and my grandfather also he was young
enough that he came back and served
in world war ii so as a as a combat
surgeon
um and then of course all the men go off
to world war ii uh so yeah they
they had these stories and i think the
stories helped him one of the reasons
uh that i wrote the book c stories was
because the stories that my father told
i know helped him
and that group deal with the challenges
that they had
in life stories help you do that as you
well know
and and frankly writing the stories and
the book c stories kind of helped me
it was it was cathartic you know you put
these stories down on paper
you remember them you remember the
people you remember your emotions
uh and it's frankly helpful to get those
stories out sometimes
yeah the so did your dad stay in the
army so was he a career army guy the
career
he joined the army air corps which
became the air force so yeah he spent 26
years in the air force retired as
colonel
um and flew until he had a heart attack
something about
whiskey and cigarettes and had a heart
attack while we were over in france
and so that took him offline status they
sent him back to
to fort sam houston actually to brooke
air force base or to lachlan air force
base the brook medical center there
recovered and then retired out of
lachlan
and you were growing up you were what
was your behavior like i know you got a
pretty good story in there that's
you know you obviously had a mischievous
side which i guess is just what we're
born with
uh but you were also a really good
athlete
uh yeah it was uh mischievous is a good
way to describe it
you know and to your point i think that
was the nature of a lot of kids back
then
you know i grew up born in 1955 but kind
of grew up in the 60s and this was a
time when
you know the the movies were about spies
you know i mean james bond came out the
the there was i spy on tv and the man
from uncle and
and even though you know i grew up in
texas and it was about cowboys and
indian sort of thing
the spy culture back then really kind of
i think grabbed the young kid certainly
grabbed me
so yeah you know we were always looking
at missions to go on and
you know when i was when i was uh
pre-teen
of course a couple of those got me in
some some serious trouble um
and yeah i was good athlete but i was
small i didn't really start growing
until late in high school
so my my dad happened to have been a
professional athlete he played football
for the cleveland rams
running back for the cleveland rams and
did that and that's where he made all of
his money yeah
i think he told me they paid him 120 a
week
which was good money back then and then
he would get 10
for doing wheaties commercials so uh so
he seemed like he was making pretty good
money uh back then but he and a bunch of
buddies saw that the
you know in the in the late 30s early
40s that war was brewing and they
i think he told me one time he and four
of his uh of his friends on the football
team just got up drove to california
and signed up for the army air corps
so you're you're what about grades were
you interested in school did you care
about
yourself yeah yeah of course i cared
about school i'm not sure school cared
that much about me uh you know i was
i was an average student i was an
average student in elementary school and
junior high school in high school
and in college uh but but i worked hard
you know i mean i worked hard to get the
grades uh i didn't have a lot of skills
in math and science
um and and of course when i look back on
my college career
i mean i changed majors four times it
wasn't until i got into
journalism which is what i ended up
graduating in
that i found out i i had a little bit of
a talent for writing
uh so i mean i couldn't do i started off
in pre-med
in college that didn't work out so well
i went to accounting that worked out
even worse
and then i went to the news reporting
and then finally in the broader
arena of journalism and so uh
when you're going to college did you did
you have a military career in mind at
that point
yeah i did uh yeah again i had watched
my
my dad and his friends and the one thing
i loved about the military
uh was just the camaraderie uh yeah even
even after my dad retired we lived in a
uh a residential area in san antonio
called wind crest and wind crest is
where a lot of the
retired military and a lot of the active
duty military lived so it was almost
like living on base housing
and so all the kids you know had some
sort of connection to the military
um and it was just a great environment
to grow up in
and i remembered a young age i decided i
kind of
my dad didn't push me this wasn't the
great santini sort of thing
but i just uh i enjoyed uh you know
watching how my parents
interacted with their friends and i said
yeah that's kind of what i want to do
and my dad wanted me to be a pilot and
my
my mom wanted me uh to be a doctor
the doctor was not going to work out as
she quickly found out
but she did get me an rotc scholarship
she had to do all the work you know
again back then
i don't think i had the discipline to do
all the paperwork my mom worked all the
paperwork and said you know go to this
interview
sign this do this and i got an rotc
scholarship to
the university of texas at austin and
that kind of put me on the path
how how had you heard about the seal
teams at this point uh so
interestingly enough my sister uh was
dating an army green beret and this was
probably 1971
and of course the movie the green beret
with john wayne had come out and i
i love the movie never heard of seals at
that point in time
and so this army officer comes a young
captain comes to pick her up and this
was at a time when
it was very unusual because the vietnam
war was still going on you weren't
supposed to wear your class a's you know
your your uniform out
in in public back then um but he comes
to pick her up and he's in his uniform
and he's a green beret and so my sister
notoriously late so i'm kind of
entertaining the guy i'm about 16 17
years old i guess
and and he says well what are you going
to do and i said well you know i'm
looking at going to the navy and rotc
and he says well then you need to be a
navy seal
i'd never heard of navy seals and he had
just come back from a tour in vietnam he
goes let me tell you
seals are the best guys in the navy if
you want to do something special you go
be a navy seal i'm thinking
this is an army green beret telling me
to go be a navy seal
and that really is kind of what spurred
me and then there was one article you
know back then not like it is today of
course
back then you couldn't find out about
seals but i got on micro fish in the
library
i found one article called uh men with
green faces
kind of it's a classic but it was it was
in some old men's magazine you know back
then they used to have these men's
magazines
and uh adventure magazine sort of thing
and i must have read that article
you know a hundred times trying to find
out what it was like of course there was
nothing on buds it was all about the
teams
interestingly enough about probably 10
years 15 years later
i found that article the micro fish you
know photocopy of it
and of course i knew all the guys in the
article it was ed bowen and it was bob
mabry and it was
it was a bob gormley i mean guys that
now i was kind of serving with
that were actually in the article so it
was uh it was interesting
now you made you you talk about this and
um in make your bed
you you go to visit buds was this like
your junior year
yeah it was between my junior and senior
year um
and you know we had some time off in the
summer and uh so i wanted to go see what
what buds was all about um so i took a
flight to san diego
and i show up at the compound uh which
is i guess they're demolishing it now
but uh so this was 1976.
and i show up and i and i go to the
quarter deck kind of unannounced and i
i i tell them i'd like to see somebody
talk about
going through bud's training so the
lieutenant who was running at the time
this guy named doug youth vietnam vet
very distinguished great great officer
and so i'm waiting outside and i
i look down the hallway and i remember
this very vividly and i see this guy
down the hallway and of course
you remember how it's set up you know
the offices are off to one side and we
back then with the
there was these posters and they were
you know vietnam era posters you know
manly men doing manly things many guys
with bandoliers on guys in the mud with
the
stoner and and this guy is kind of
looking up at these posters
you know kind of you know longingly and
and looking at i'm thinking to myself
you have got to be kidding me
i mean this guy you know he was thin
kind of frail
um and had a little bit of a mop of of
long hair and i thought he was a
dependent you know
but he's kind of looking up and i'm
thinking man does this guy
really think he could be a navy seal
doesn't he know i mean maybe steel's
supposed to look like me you know six
foot two eyes of blue big brawny guys
and so as i'm watching this guy you know
i'm waiting and thinking i feel sorry
for this guy if he really thinks that he
could make it through seal training
so a few minutes later i get called into
heath's office and i'm sitting there
talking to doug youth and out of the
corner of my eye i can see this guy kind
of walking
across in front of the doorway and
finally doug huth stops me he goes
hey bill hold on say i want to introduce
you to somebody he said tommy tommy come
in here
he says bill this is uh tommy norris
he's the last seal
medal of honor recipient from fiat and
of course as you well know jocko
tommy one of the toughest guys that ever
went through seal training
and it just reinforced the fact and of
course when you get in sealed training
you realize this
it ain't about how big you are it ain't
about how fast you are
i mean tommy norris one of the toughest
guys because uh
you know he had the he had the heart uh
big enough to make it through the
toughness the determination everything
that we're looking for in seals
and so a lot of guys that go through
that think it's all about you know how
fast you can run and how much you can
bench press and
they're missing the point uh the tommy
norris's of this world so the ones that
that rule the teams crazy how many uh
guys with a big bench or a great run
time quit
yeah it's nuts right saw it early on we
had this
we had two guys that looked like weight
lifters i don't think they made it
through the first week that's that's not
not what you're looking for as you know
and uh lieutenant hughes who checked you
in the first phase he was the
he was the ceo of all of bud's when i
went oh sorry yeah he was he was the
captain in charge of the secretary going
through
so uh so you you end up going back
finishing your senior year
and then you got you got orders but was
it hard to get to go to buds then
it wasn't uh again back then buds was
actually
a course at the naval amphibious school
so it was not its own command it was
just a
course that was run at the naval and
phibic school and when i got orders i
was at the university of texas
i remember my orders came in and it
didn't say
basic underwater demolition seal
training it had a course number on it
and it said something about explosives
training but that was about it
and so i didn't even know whether these
were the right orders
to go to buds so i'm calling around but
again back then
nobody knew about seal training so you
know the
one of the officers had to call the
detailer who back then our detailers and
for your audience the detailers
are the guys that that send you give you
the orders where to go
well we didn't have a sealed detailer
back then it was an eod an explosive
ordinance disposal officer
that managed the seal community so yeah
he said
i don't know it's it's the course number
so of course i show up turned out it was
the right place to go
well uh we just had bill posey on yeah
and
he showed up to buds whatever course
number it was
same thing and he thought it was of
course he he asked like hey do i need a
backpack for the books and like what do
you think you need books for he says for
the course
he had no idea what he was doing he
thought he was going to go he's got
thought he's going to some kind of
advanced
dive hard hat dive school or something
like that
and i was also thinking about dick
thompson we had
a guy named dick thompson on who was a
green beret in vietnam
so he joined the army voluntarily then
he volunteered for
special forces then he volunteered for
ocs when became an officer
and i said hey was it hard to you know
when you
was it hard to get those billets and he
goes no
because it was vietnam they were like oh
you want to be an officer
cool go ahead you want to be in special
forces cool go ahead do you want to join
the army everything was easy
well and i don't uh except all you have
to do is pass the pt test
and of course you know the pt test is
not all that hard uh
you pass pt test you get orders to buds
i mean i think it was that easy back
then
and now again i can't i can't talk to
the naval academy guys but for those of
us in rotc hey if you raised your hand
and you wanted to go
you were probably going to get a bullet
did you have any idea what you were
getting into
none none whatsoever again there were no
books there were no movies there was
nothing on seal training
i knew nothing about what we were going
to do i just knew that i wasn't going to
quit
they were they were going to have to
kill me if they were going to stop me
from getting through
how was your water competency yeah good
i mean i was a good swimmer okay uh and
i've been scuba diving since i was 13.
so i learned dive young um
so the water i mean i thought we'd
actually spend more time of course we
did spend a lot of time swimming but i
was always good swimmer so that was not
an issue yeah i think that's a big
that's a big problem for guys that show
up from iowa that
didn't you know they grew up wrestling
and weightlifting or whatever but they
didn't swim and that's a problem
or particularly swimming in the surf
yeah i mean there's a difference as you
know i mean
you can get in the pool and make pretty
good laps but there were a lot of kids
that came in
with me that all of a sudden that you
know you see the surf particularly in
the the winter time off coronado
and you know you get 10 12 foot breakers
and they're like whoa never seen that
before
so that was a bit of a shock for him and
then your class leader
uh was was daniel stewart daniel stewart
yeah one of the finest officers uh i
ever served with and daniel had been
rolled back he had uh
as you recall and towards the end of the
first phase of training
uh or maybe it was right before uh hell
week uh we did um
cast and recovery so you take an
inflatable boat small and you tied up
along what we had was called pl which
was a little
small uh boat back then and then you
hooked the old classic
frogman in world war ii you hook your
arm through the sling well in the course
of hooking
his arm through the sling the guy caught
the arm too low ripped out his bicep
and so daniel had to get rolled back
fortunately for us he ends up
being a class leader and he was
lieutenant jg the other officers in the
class we were all insanes
and daniel had been in the fleet so he
was already a surface warfare officer
naval academy graduate exactly the guy
we needed
uh to frankly get through training again
i knew nothing about what i was stepping
into and neither did the other two
officers uh
that were with us we were all you know
kind of bright-eyed and bushy-tailed but
uh
but daniel had already been through it
had some great great ideas on how we
were going to make it through and
he's the one that got us through frankly
he was my first commanding officer at
seal team one
and he was i guess in the modern term
that we would say we he
would say he was jacked yeah he was like
still is yeah and
because he was a gymnast wasn't he a
gymnast so he was the first human being
because i didn't know anything about
gymnastics but he was out on the old
pull-up bar
behind sale team one and he was doing
muscle-ups on the pull-up bar
i didn't even know what that was and i
remember thinking damn i got some work
to do over here
that's a new guy um
the instructors so you've got i mean
this is first of all they're basically
unchanged there's no supervision
there was no adult supervision right
well i think there was but of course
as as trainees you don't think there is
uh
and you think they have the latitude to
do anything to you so
i think that was part of the
psychological advantage they had was if
there was in fact adult supervision
which i think there was and i think they
had certain criteria
we didn't know it so i think today again
the students going through
because they have such a good
understanding they know the instructors
aren't going to kill them
i can be honest with you i'm not sure we
knew that back then uh
and some of them seemed mean enough to
do that uh but they were all vietnam
vets
uh you know these you know salty old
crusty old guys and uh
and of course as a young kid i mean you
look up to these vietnam vets as we
should
uh great combat experience uh great
stories and you wanted to be like these
guys
and of course they wanted you to be
tough enough mentally tough enough
physically tough enough
to join them in the teams and you knew
that was the standard you were fighting
for
so uh it was great to have those guys
be your instructors because you know we
looked up to them so much and we just
wanted to
do the best by them what was
was it like just the normal kind of 75
or 80 attrition rate yeah same thing
uh we started with uh i went back and
had to check the numbers
we started with 110 guys at least that's
what the roster shows we ended up with
um so right about the same nutrition and
yet 33
back then was a large class the class
before us i think had finished with
18 or 20 which was about normal back
then again i attribute a lot of
our success to daniel stewart who
managed to keep the
class together during the tough times um
and they were they were actually very
impressed remember the instructors
watched us very closely
because we got a lot of guys through uh
hell week i think we ended up
getting almost 55 guys through hell week
and we lost a lot of guys after that
but still ending up with 33 guys was a
large class and the instructors were
trying to figure out
how did you guys do that because we need
to get more guys through
well the answer was you had great
leadership and
that always helps when you're in in
challenging situations yeah
did um i know you you talk a little bit
about in the
in one of the books about uh instructor
faculty
who ended up being my first master chief
at seal team one
and he's a guy that uh really instilled
well the professionalism because
in the seal teams especially i would say
more so back then but there was
like a a professional side and there was
an equally strong sort of hell's angel
sort of sort of spirit that you could
jump into and and
like great guys on both sides um i think
that mass chief faculty for me
sort of leaned me and kind of my group
at least put some level of hey you got
to be squared away you got to present
yourself
you you know this is the military where
in the navy like all those
little things which you go to some other
some other deeper darker
aos and the seal teams there was none of
that going on
and and i i just appreciated that fact
and it like i said it had a
it had a good influence on me because
when you're young and impressionable
i just wanted to be a good seal right
and if you told me a good seal was
having a good haircut and wearing a
square away uniform okay that's what i'm
doing
luckily people like that were around
yeah and and i think he nailed it choco
i mean
that was consistent with what i saw with
faculty throughout his career and as we
talked
before the podcast you know mike and i
became very good friends we were
neighbors in chula vista
uh and he and daniel stewart stayed very
very good friends
so mike was actually our proctor again
for your listener so the proctor was the
the senior enlisted that really was in
charge of your phase so he was our first
phase proctor
and and that was really important
because it kind of sets the tone for the
rest of the three phases
but faculty as the proctor and daniel
stewart as the class leader
uh you know they they worked well
together and faculty
would you know give us little tips on
you know how to get through certain
evolutions and events kind of passed
through daniel stewart so that team
that teamwork between faculty as a
proctor and steward as the
as a class leader was helpful but mike
was always professional i mean he was
prof
and as you know the instructors love to
harass you uh
and you know some of them harass you
with a little bit of a mean spirit
some of them have uh a good sense of
humor and of course faculty could always
do it with a little bit of a twinkle in
his eye
uh i mean let's not say you you weren't
suffering the pain you were suffering
the pain
uh but there was always a little smile a
little bit of a twinkle in his eye
and you knew that he was gonna you know
get you through this evolution even
though he was gonna
you know harass you to the max
yeah the uh the other thing i think i
learned
well again never really broke it down
like this but this sort of professional
side versus this kind of hells angel
side
i think what i what what i learned from
faculty was
that what we were there to do was
was do the do the mission of the country
right and if you wanted to do that if
that's what you were there there to do
to kill bad guys to go out and execute
operations which look this is the 90s
when i showed up there was
i missed the first gulf war but as far
as i could tell if you wanted to do that
if you wanted to actually do the
missions for the country then you had to
be professional right and that was the
connection that i kind of made
and and and by the way you know the idea
of being a
a frog man what could what could
possibly trump
doing being a good operator for being a
frogman there's nothing that trumps that
it's not
any of that other stuff that you can
that there's plenty of in the seal teams
but
there's there's nothing that trumps hey
i'm a good i want to be a good operator
i want to be able to do my job well i
want to go out and execute missions
and that professionalism i think is a i
mean it was a key component for me
and my career and uh something that i
think people like
master chief faculty embedded in enough
people that it
it carries on no you know you're exactly
right the fact of the matter is
uh there was a little bit of the
the duality of if you will of the kind
of the hell's angels and the
professionals but even the hell's angels
understood
that if you were going to do a complex
seal mission boy you better have the
highest standards possible
you better know your business you better
rehearse it to the nth degree
you are not going to come in and be
cavalier about people's lives or about
making sure that we're going to be
successful on a mission
so i mean again i was fortunate i had a
guy named
lieutenant john wright and john was a
young
uh you know probably incident or
lieutenant jg in vietnam
but when i got to underwater demolition
team 11 john kind of took me under his
wing
and it was all about the professionalism
and at first was okay ensign mcraven you
need to learn the basics you need to
know
everything you can find out about
demolition about parachuting
about weapons you better be able to
break apart every single weapon because
john wright could do that
now you know you you had that
expectation if you're one of these
senior enlisted guys
but his expectation was you can't lead
the men under you
if you don't know the skill set it
equally as well at the end of the day
you you never know it quite as good as
the enlisted guys do
but you want to make sure you've put in
the effort and so john instilled in me
hey you got to work hard every single
day you've got to earn their respect
every single day the day you think you
don't have to earn their respect that
you've become so senior
or you've become so entitled then you're
the wrong person to be leading and that
was instilled to me
at a very young age fortunately my
faculty and i ended up working together
a number of times and later he became my
command master chief
uh and uh and to your point jocko i mean
he was a guy that set the standards high
and expected everybody to meet the
standards
or exceed the standards and and the
standards were the standards
and i don't care whether you were his
friend uh or or somebody he didn't like
if you could meet the standards
then you were gonna be a good teammate
before we jump into udt11 um it sounded
like you almost had a damn helo crash at
the end of buds
we did uh yeah so uh
it was the very last day of buds
training
and this was the the next day we were
going to graduate back at the time
you know when you finished bud's
training that's when you had the big
graduation you didn't get your triton
then
but all the parents would come out so
this was the day before the graduation
and and the last evolution was
helicopter cast and recovery
and so the parents that had come out for
the graduation the following day
all showed up on turner field and turner
field as an area here in coronado where
the helicopters would land they put some
bleachers out there for all the parents
to sit in
and of course the instructor who at the
time was lieutenant moki martin
you know makes the parents think that
you know here your sons are about to be
navy frogmen you know
and and this is a this is a really tough
evolution it's a dangerous evolution
and so he kind of built up the hype a
little bit for all the parents when in
fact as you know helicopter cast and
recovery is a pretty straightforward
operation
so myself and dale stewart actually were
the first two sticks so we board the
uh the 46 the navy 46 and and so we go
out
picked up off turner field we fly out
over the bay and the idea is you know
they drop
each stick off and they stick i think we
had seven or eight guys on the stick
and so daniel is the first stick out and
i'm the first guy in the second stick
so i get dropped off while the helo
comes back around picks up daniel's guys
picks up me i'm the first guy in the
stick and as i get into the helicopter
i sit down in the on the bench seat and
i'm thinking yeah this doesn't look
quite right
i'm up to my waist in water and i'm
thinking i don't think the helo is
supposed to be doing
of course as i look in the cockpit here
are the pilots there are fighting the
helo
the uh the crew chief we had actually
landed we lost power in one of the
engines so
the helicopter had settled hard into the
water and one of the guys who was about
to be picked up through the hell hole
gets landed on and so now the crew chief
he's running back trying to make sure
this guy didn't get knocked out
uh but now as the helicopter is slowly
starting to sink
we were following instructions and back
then the instructions were
okay gentlemen if a helicopter lands in
the water everybody stays seated
the helicopter will sink it will roll
over and you just swim out after that
of course we're not smart enough to
realize that's a really bad idea
but but you know it was about 30 feet
deep where we were doing this so we
thought ah no big deal
if it sinks down we'll we'll swim out
well
uh so finally as the helo is kind of
slowly starting to sink the crew chief
realizes
got to get the weight out of the back
well we're looking at the side door and
of course that that blade is like almost
clipping the water
and it's like how about this but he's
giving us the ghost sign so we all dive
out
well the pilot's got no control of
helicopter so now as we're all out
trying to swim towards the safety boat
who is always going
i don't think i'm coming the helo starts
to kind of
follow us and finally uh you know we all
get out of get out of harm's way
and the helo i mean the pilot uh good
pilot i mean after
about an hour and a half he manages
literally to drive the helo
off to point golf you know that point
over there and beach the helo
so he saves the helicopter and nobody
got injured but the funny part about it
was as i got told later
so the parents are all in the bleachers
and and lieutenant martin is telling
this story about you know you know
helicopter casually says and then all of
a sudden all the parents got up they ran
past me
what's going on and of course the
helicopter landed in the water
and i remember faculty as we we got back
to the uh
got back to the beach he said something
to the effect of
boy i hope this isn't an indication of
how the rest of your career is going to
go
and of course it was an indication of
how the rest of the career would go
that's uh that's good times yeah um
so now you go to udt11 and uh
check into udt11 and look like i said i
didn't want to read i don't want to read
a ton of stuff from the books today
because you
did this stuff on audiobook but you
captured the check-in process at a
sealed team and this was a udt team
which
later became seal teams but i just i
just had to go this is this is going to
the book the hero code to your latest
book
and this is what it like checking into a
team so you're the new guy
one of my officers remarked yes sir i
responded it's my first day in the teams
first day in the teams well you're gonna
love it here he said
the guys will welcome you with open arms
the old vietnam vets are really nice
they love officers
particularly new officers they'll treat
you really well
great i'm looking forward to it so there
we go out of the gate it's uh
you can see where this is going a sly
grin came across the officer's face
dressed in khaki swim trunks blue and
gold t-shirts jungle boots we headed out
to of the building
and on the grinder after a short daily
briefing from the executive officer we
broke ranks and formed up into a circle
the pt circle and then it began
so ensign and you are an ensign at this
time that's the lowest officer rank in
the navy so ensign i understand you went
to texas a m
no chief the university of texas not
texas a m
so you couldn't get into a real school
huh before i could answer
someone else offered a response he's
from texas there aren't any real schools
in texas
ah so you weren't smart enough to get
into the academy we frogmen expect our
officers to be smart what did you major
in
i hesitated journalism chief
journalism you're a damn reporter hey
exo we don't need no damn reporter in
our ranks
the executive officer smiled but said
nothing what seal training class were
you in
a man at the far end of the circle
shouted class 95 i yelled back
you got to be kidding me an older
officer said spitting out a lot of
tobacco i heard class
95 was the easiest class ever they had a
summer hell week
over the next 15 minutes all 50 men in
the circle had something to say about my
shortfalls
in between repetitions of push-ups
flutter kicks sit-ups and burpees
they questioned my parentage my
athleticism my intellect
my state of origin the quality of my
seal training class and of course
my love life you got a girlfriend one of
the salty old chiefs
asked i do chief what's she look like
oh she's pretty very petite brown hair
hazel eyes about five foot four the
chief smiled
do you think she'd like a swarthy
italian with a mustache he said twirling
the ends of his long handlebar
i saw an opening no chief i said looking
around the grinder
she likes men that are taller than she
is
the circle went quiet the chief who
stood no longer than
five no taller than five foot four got
up off the grinder and walked up to
where i was standing
inches from my face he sneered at me and
said are you calling me
short the men in the circle were shaking
their heads one mouth don't go there
anson
another said softly he's very sensitive
about his height
well chief you are looking up at me i
told him
everyone in the grinder stopped
exercising and turned my way
what do you think that's funny ensign do
you think insulting a chief petty
officer in the united states navy is
funny
i am very very sensitive about my height
and that hurts me
i paused wondering whether i had taken
my my
my joke too far suddenly the chief burst
out laughing
and the rest of the men in the circle
joined in welcome to the teams ensign
when the physical training ended the
chief and all the other members of the
team came by to shake my hand and
welcomed me to udt 11.
i had passed the test i had a sense of
humor
good way to check in you've been there
before you know the deal
[Music]
so i was uh i did the semen admiral
program
and i got went straight from officer
from seal team one as an e5 went to
officer kennedy school for 13 weeks went
to
seal team two as an ensign so i hadn't
been to college it was a ridiculous
program
i feel like maybe i can get arrested for
it or something because it was
such a good deal well and then i did two
deployments at seal team two
and then i went to college so i was an
officer in college
but it was the i've been in the seal
teams my whole adult life
and so now i'm going to college and i'm
coming home
and you know i don't have anyone to
banter with so it ends up being my wife
and and after that could be dangerous
yeah after about two or three months
finally you know i said something about
the meal she had made or
what she had prepared or something like
this and she looked at me and she goes
hey i'm not a team guy and i was
yeah and i i kind of chuckled but then i
i realized she was 100 right
you know the the the the lifestyle of
being in a platoon where it's just
constant attacks from everybody
um it's it's it's a
it's an environment that you get so used
to you don't realize that that's just
the way it is
and and that may actually be the best
part as you know about being in the
teams
uh and and for your listeners i mean
every morning
back then kind of pre-911 we had the pt
circle
and come hell or high water you know you
were gonna break out and you were gonna
do pt for
probably an hour hour and a half and the
pt circle was where
boy if if you were not on your toes you
know somebody was gonna rip you apart
and and back to the point it was this
sense of humor this this camaraderie
that was built in the pt circle and in
the locker room
that then of course transitioned on to
the to the missions
and you would see guys in in you know
very tough situations
all of a sudden crack a joke and that is
i think the power
of being in the team sometimes is you
build this
uh this this level of teamwork with your
uh
with your swim buddies that is hard to
replicate anywhere
and and if there's one thing i miss um
after retiring
many things but that's the thing i miss
the most is being around team guys
being harassed harassing people back and
realizing that hey no harm no foul you
know just let's move on
it's fun when you checked into udt11
what what did you think you were going
to be doing so just
as a little backdrop when i checked into
seal team one
in 1991 i thought i was going to nom
like in my mind i was like hey look man
i know we don't know about this stuff
there's top secret stuff going on i know
i'm probably going to nom or whatever
cambodia i'm going to be doing sog
missions
that's what i was thinking because i was
really young and really dumb
when you checked into udt11 what was it
1977.
early 1978. what did you think you were
going to be doing same thing
i mean i'm not you're good well back
then of course we thought we were going
to go back and rescue pows out of
vietnam yeah
or this was the cold war kind of the
height of the cold war so we thought we
were going to be doing missions against
the soviet union
and i don't think i mentioned the story
in any of the books but
when i when i first got there i was out
doing a dive
training dive one day and and one of the
chiefs comes grabs me and says hey sir
uh canadian officer wants to see you
i mean i'm an insulin commanding officer
i mean he's an important guy and i
thought
all right this is it i mean the
commanding officer i mean it's
something important so i i get up and he
and i said well let me go back and
change you guys not ceo said just come
come as you are i was in my shorty
wetsuit so i go up go and
wait outside the ceo's office and the
ceo's assistant says yeah going to see
him and
i had met the ceo but yeah i mean i was
in ensign he was the commanding officer
so i come in and he says vincent mcraven
you know good to see you again
yes sir he says uh i've been hearing
good things about you and i'm thinking
yeah okay he says he says look we got
something important coming up
and uh and yeah i need one of my best
instances to kind of run this thing i'm
like yeah
this is this is what i've been waiting
for you know there it comes
and he says you know the fourth of july
is coming up and we need somebody to be
the frog float
officer and of course i'm like
i'm sorry sir what yeah you know every
fourth of july we build a frog float
to be in the coronado parade and i want
you to be the frog float officer
and i was like you have got to be
kidding me but i remember when i came
out i kind of had this kind of hound dog
look on my face and there was a
i don't remember hershel davis yeah so
hershel davis was the command master
over at seal team
over underwater demolition team 12 and
he sees me walking die and i'm a little
han
you know like shoulders down he goes
what's wrong hansen
that's uh masturbating i sit up and then
i thought it was going to do some
important i'm going to be the frog float
officer
and herschel said something he said well
then be the best damn frog float officer
you can be
and i thought no that's it right there
whatever it is whether you're the frog
float officer or plant in the eelgrass
which was another one we had to do
do it the best you can i mean eelgrass
plant eelgrass so the reason
coronado san diego bay looks as good as
it does and as clean as it is
is because back in 1978 udt12 udt11 and
seal team one we all got out
and planted eelgrass underwater so that
eelgrass would grow to bring in the
little fishies to clean out
san diego bay and it worked but that was
hours of diving at three feet under the
water planting
eelgrass yeah i never i never did do
those missions to uh
to get the soviet union or to go back
into vietnam but i was on my first
deployment
so i get to we deployed to guam and we
show up there
and they immediately have us do uh like
a double duck
insert we go in we hit a target
live fire we come over the beach hit a
target live fire we get done
we're all you know pretty it's pretty
cool and then we go out the next day we
clean our weapons we go out they say hey
you know get your weapons sighted in
okay you know and of course same thing
in my mind
i'm thinking we're getting ready for the
big mish so we go out we sight in our
weapons
clean them set them in get back and then
a couple days goes by and they give us
pagers too right
which back in the day you know you might
as well just you know it was
it was just as as crazy as it gets so i
got the pager
well a couple days go by three days four
days go by and we're not getting the big
recall
you know i don't know if they're trying
to negotiate with whoever the terrorists
were that were needed to die or whatever
the case was
but also there was good waves so i said
you know what
i told my told my roommate like a couple
of us are gonna go surfing so we went
down the spanish steps
and we were surfing and all of a sudden
i'm looking up on the cliffs and there's
the guy that we told is up there waving
his arms frantically
and holy [ __ ] right we're getting
recalled this is it so
run in run up the spanish steps grab you
know hey what's going on we got recalled
shows me his pager he's got the 911 page
damn it's on
we get back we get down to the platoon
space
and uh you know the freaking senior
chief comes in and he says uh
hey you guys you you didn't clean up
your brass on the
range after you set in your weapons you
guys got to go clean up your best
so that was when i realized it maybe
wasn't gonna quite
i wasn't going to nom after all
um how long were you how long did you
udt 11 then
uh two years and did you did you do a
platoon there were you like an assistant
platoon
i was an assistant platoon commander uh
dave tash lieutenant dave tash was the
platoon commander i was in an sdv
platoon
so you know when i first got there of
course thinking
i was going to do real frogman stuff and
being a regular underwater demolition
team platoon which was
as you know this was about kind of
clearing beaches and that sort of thing
and then i find out there are these
things called
back then swimmer delivery vehicles now
seal delivery vehicles
and uh and at first i was uh i wasn't
happy about being assigned to an sdv
platoon
turned out to be one of the one of the
best platoons i was ever in it was just
it was real frogman stuff because we
were doing you know six hour dives and
our
so for again the listener and sdv is a
you know think about a manned torpedo
with a bit bit of a cowling on it so you
had a uh
we started off what was called the mark
seven so you had a pilot in the front
and a navigator in the back
and you could squeeze two more guys in
if you had to and you could put some
demolition in there and then
and then they would launch off the
bigger submarines and then later we got
the mark
8 which was a bigger uh steel delivery
vehicle
but it was all about diving i mean you
spent you know four days a week
uh underwater yeah and an important
thing to note about this
when you say mini submarine there's a
key component that
is not what you're thinking if you're
listening this and that is it's it's a
wet submersible so you're not in this
thing dry
you're diving while you're in a you're
basically on a motorcycle
underwater underwater yeah so uh so i
was
one of the primary pilots and uh and i i
loved driving the sdv and of course uh
you know as i'm back here in coronado
california and i had a chance to go back
i mean
you relived those days where you were
going under the bridge and back then you
had what was called an obstacle
avoidance sonar
and the oas as we referred to it yeah
the underwater obstacles were not real
clear you really had to have a good eye
to be able to read the obstacle void and
sonar
so the navigator would read the oas and
it was just kind of green glow and you'd
have to pick out the pylons and the
and the ships coming at you underwater
in this green glow
they've gotten much better today but
back then the technology just wasn't
very good
so we tended to run into things every
once in a while you know
ships the coronado bay bridge you know
and then you just it was fiberglass so
you bring it back in and the
master chief who was our fiberglass guru
would you give you that look like i
can't believe you ran into something
again and
he'd fix up the fiberglass and get back
in the water did you go on
a deployment i did yeah did a first west
back so i went over to subic bay that's
where naval special warfare unit 1 was
in subic bay at the time
and the uss gray back which was our
special operations submarine
so the grayback had these two big
chambers on it that used to launch
regulus missiles
and they had converted these chambers uh
to be able to launch the
steel delivery vehicles so we went out
there and
again spent a lot of time underway on
board the uss greyback conducting
training operations once again thinking
we were going to go
you know run against vladivostok or
something like that so there was always
uh and you remember the time you know
when when you were training
one of the things that always motivated
you was this could become a real world
mission sometime
you know if you ever got to the point
where you were training and you didn't
think that you were going to be able to
take that training and apply it in
wartime
then i think it demotivated you but the
fact matter is every time we went out on
a training app there was
always this idea that oh we're going
against the soviets
or you know we're going to go back in
vietnam and get the pows that might
still be there or
we're going to go do some you know some
of the nation's bidding somewhere
and that always pushed you to do
absolutely your very best on every
single training mission no matter how
hard it was
even though as a training op you wanted
to push it to the limits because you
wanted to be ready for the real world up
yeah and there was also this
i don't know if it's a specter but this
belief that this real world mission
whatever it was going to be
since it was a little bit unknown you
you didn't you didn't know
it you didn't know what it was going to
be so it was always like i need to
prepare
even more even more because we just
don't even know how crazy it's going to
be right
then how long so so you did one
deployment to this to subic bay and then
you got done with that
and then you got did you get stationed
at super bay right now yeah so i had
my first set of orders to the naval post
graduate school and i ended up having
five sets of orders of which
i didn't execute the first forum because
i got pulled out to go do something else
but yeah as soon as i got back i guess i
had made an impression a good impression
on the commanding officer out there in
subic
so i got back thinking i was going to go
to a wonderful tour in monterey
california and
as soon as i got back the commanding
officer says hey good news
the commanding officer of naval special
warfare unit 1 has asked for you
by name and you get to go to the
philippines for two years
and i thought this is going to be tough
and
once again it turned out to be an
absolutely fabulous tour
my wife and i went out there mar my
first child was all of a couple of
months old at that time
and uh you know we worked hard in the
philippines supporting the platoons that
would deploy over so back then
unit one in the philippines the platoons
from san diego
would deploy out there that was kind of
our home base and then they would go
from there to other places
but unit one had the responsibility of
supporting them so i got there i started
off as the intelligence officer
and then since he kind of became the
utility infielder
the training officer and a lot of other
things um but it was a great group of
guys out there
good mission and uh and life in the
philippines back then was a
was a good time you relay one of these
training operations in
in the book c stories that i would say
left a mark on you you
you were basically running a training
mission you had a marine colonel that
was playing the role of a hostage
so he was being held out in a jungle
camp somewhere
and he's out there for a few days and
then you know the seal team
the seal platoon gets the tasking to go
out and rescue this guy
and it well it doesn't go well you know
they get compromised
and it it sort of falls on its face but
the
the marine colonel um you know colonel
browse is that how you say his name
colonel browse
he he was like hey listen we already we
already did this much let's continue to
execute the rest of the plan even though
it wasn't great
let's just continue doing it so they to
finish the exercise they had to
move the kernel to an extraction point
where he was going to get picked up by
uh
by c-130s and then the c-130s were gonna
take him on a low-level flight and and
you know you're in what are you
lieutenant jg at this point joj
right you've had this this colonel out
in the field for three four days and you
say hey sir you know you don't
we can get you back to base and he's
like no let's just get it done let's
let's do the let's do the whole thing
and a little more time goes by and you
say hey sir you know you don't really
need to get in this plane it's not going
to be any training value for you and he
says no you know we'll
we'll just do it it's what a good leader
does like they don't just
you know bust out when when things are
going to get boring
um but then there's another delay
the c-130s that are supposed to pick
them up are they they're late they're
delayed
and finally delayed multiple times and
and finally you say you know hey sir
like we don't know when this is going to
happen
why don't you just you know you and i
will get out of here you can go and of
course he's a colonel he's got stuff to
do he's got work to do so you
he knows that too so finally he says
look you know what you're right
i got to get back to work and so he
doesn't get on the c-130 you don't get
on the c-130
um c-130 takes off with with um
a bunch of americans australians new
zealand
some filipinos on there and i'm just
going to go to the book here
browse that's the colonel brows and i
returned to a waiting jeep i shook his
hand thanked him for helping out with
the exercise and watched a young petty
officer escort him
back to subic exhausted i jumped in
another jeep and drove home
it had been a long couple of days half
an hour later aboard the mc-130
call signed stray 59 the pilot checked
his instruments
like the rest of us the preceding days
for him and his crew had been long and
tiring
adjusting his night vision goggles he
could see the water just a few
a few feet below him the water was
closer than expected
too close to recover the tip of the left
wing caught the top of a small wave
and in an instant the plane tumbled
forward exploding in a fuel-injected
ball of flame
as it violently ripped apart from the
impact of the aircraft and the sea
of the 24 men aboard eight crew members
and 16 passengers from the united states
australia new zealand and the
philippines
all but one air force first lieutenant
jeffrey a
bloem died in the crash
life in the seal teams always seems to
revolve around fate
or destiny or the hand of god why do
some men
live and others die why were some men
saved that day
did god have a different plan for us
what about the crew
and passengers of stray 59 surely their
families would have wanted
them longer in their lives they were all
brave and honorable men
all worthy of a full and prosperous life
i think about them often 20 years later
as i rose to the rank of admiral in
command and combat
in iraq and afghanistan became a daily
activity i thought a lot about stray 59
the role of the mc-130s and their sister
aircraft the ac-130s became more and
more important to our special
operations missions with every plan i
reviewed and every plan i approved
i asked myself silently whether the risk
to the crew and the aircraft was worth
the reward i can only hope that the
sacrifice of the men aboard
stray 59 saved lives lives of men and
women
who have no idea that their destiny
rested with a plane that took off from
qb airfield
in 1981 and never return
may god rest at their souls
real world missions and regular missions
in the military there's always
some level of risk
yeah um and as you well know
uh there are times when
you go left instead or right and it
makes a difference between life and
death you make one decision
and it changes the lives of you know
dozens of men and women and and this is
the nature of life in the teams
and i think back over those 37 years and
and i've written about a few of them in
the book but there were more of them
and and you've been there where all of a
sudden you know
you have this near-death experience you
know the parachute doesn't work
uh you know you almost uh get blown up
by one of your colleagues
a hundred things but it doesn't happen
you know
you managed to get through it uh or it
happens and and it's over and you've
survived and you go
and you don't spend a lot of time
thinking about you're like okay well uh
the reserve opened that's good uh or the
guy fired an inch from me
instead of hit me that's good um and
that's
that becomes almost a daily weekly
monthly occurrence
and you just learn to compartmentalize
you learn to live with it but there was
something about stray 59
it was obviously the magnitude of the
crash
and and just the fact that as you read
it so beautifully there
you know i had asked the colonel three
times because again he was an important
guy he was in charge of the office of
the provost
and and he was a senior marine there at
subic a great guy
and and i had kind of uh encouraged him
to be this
uh this hostage and so in the course of
the the day
which was relationship building which
was
didn't go so well but we were actually
on the ramp of the c-130
as we were getting ready the third time
and i knew you know you've been on these
flights you know the
the c-130 you know the low-level terrain
following is
i mean it's it's a vomit rocket i mean
you're just up and down and
uh and some guys don't handle it very
well um and i thought
we're gonna do that for three and a half
hours does he really need to do that and
it wasn't until we were actually
standing on the ramp when he says
yeah okay let's go um and then of course
i got the call about an
hour or so later we had to remuster in
the in the compound there at naval
special warfare
one didn't know why and of course they
were trying to get a head count to find
out who was still alive
and you have a lot of those in the
course of your career
and you hope you learn from them and as
i pointed out in the book
man when i was in a position of command
you know from the time i was
the commander of seal team 3 or the
commodore or certainly my time after 9
you're reviewing these missions and
particularly with the mc130s and the c
and the ac 130s because you know in
combat the guy they want to push the
envelope
it's okay to push the envelope but only
if the reward is worth the risk
um because you know i wanted to make and
it wasn't just the
the c-130s i mean i the helicopter
pilots i remember at one point in time
after not my uh unit but another unit
had lost a helo and a couple seals have
been on board and they'd uh
but but the mission they were running i
i thought was a little too high risk
i pulled all the warrant officers in
that were flying for me and i said we're
not going to do that
here's the deal if i find out that you
take off on a mission
that is red i'm going to fire your ass
and send you back to the states
you ought to start off every mission in
the green in other words you ought to
have planned it to reduce the risk as
much as possible if it's a really
important mission
maybe i'll let you start off in the
amber but we're going to have that
conversation
but we are not going to start off a
mission in the red
it ain't worth it if you think the
shadow governor of pickup province is
worth it is not we'll come back and get
them tomorrow
and uh and i didn't know how that would
be received by the pilots because
you know i mean i was uh you know when
you when you start losing guys and
losing helicopters
you know you you really want to make
sure you're doing things the right way
because you don't want to lose any more
men if you don't have to
and um and afterwards i had a couple of
the old salty you know warrants come up
to me and and
and they were appreciative of the fact
that hey here's the line we are not
going to do this now again
missions may go in the red i got it but
but let's not start off in the red let's
not build
you know risk into the mission uh and i
think a lot of that goes back to stray
59 to realizing that uh
your lives are on the line particularly
in these uh these aircraft by the
aircraft and the helos and everything
else we fly around
um but the interesting thing so when i
when i wrote this
i had no idea where colonel brousse was
didn't i assumed he had passed away
long since and and frankly the last time
i saw him was probably a few years after
uh probably in the in the mid 80s
well i get an email from his son
who had read the the book and he says
hey sir
my father's still alive and and i'd like
to send him a copy of this book so
uh i reach out to talk to colonel browse
he and his wife are i mean he's in his
90s
sharp as he can be and uh and he
remembered the story and again you're
always please
you remember the story exactly as i as i
presented in
in the book and uh but uh but he also
remembered the fact that uh
his life changed that day and and that
had a had a big impact on him as well
and he was a combat veteran for all from
vietnam vietnam oh yeah yeah heavily
decorated
um yeah i mean he was a a hard charge
and this was
this was not an admin marine this was a
hell of a combat vet yeah
well note if you're out there listening
um colonel browse
open invite if you want to come on here
and talk about your experiences
um i'm i'm gonna fast forward a little
bit
uh going i'm gonna go to the book make
your bed again
going to july 1983.
here we go july 1983 was one of those
tough moments
as i stood before the commanding officer
i thought my career as a navy seal was
over
i just been relieved of my seal squadron
fired for trying to change the way my
squadron was organized
trained and conducted missions there
were some magnificent officers and
enlisted men in the organization
some of the most professional warriors
i'd ever been around however much of the
culture was still rooted in the vietnam
era
and i thought that it was time for a
change as i was to find out change is
never easy
particularly for the person in charge
fortunately even though i was fired
my commanding officer allowed me to
transfer to another seal team but my
reputation as a seal officer
was severely damaged everywhere i went
other officers and enlisted men knew i
had failed and every day there were
whispers and subtle reminders
that maybe i wasn't up to the task of
being a seal
at that point in my career i had two
options quit and move on to civilian
life
which seemed like the logical choice in
the light of my recent officer fitness
report
or weather the storm and prove to others
and myself
that i was a good seal officer
i chose the latter
so here you are wanting to be a good
seal
and you tried to implement some changes
you i guess swam against the stream
when you look back at that you know this
is this is a a subject that i've
talked about a lot because well um
there's a book called about face by
colonel david hackworth and
and you know at the end of the vietnam
war he
went on a tv program called issues and
answers and and said
we're gonna lose this war if we don't
change the way we're fighting it and he
was drummed out of the army in another
couple of months and
and my debate is always you know he was
a golden child in the army at that point
and
would have absolutely been up for
brigade command and division command and
who had been in charge of
tens of thousands if not more and could
have really
influenced the way the war was fought
but he spoke up and you know that was it
made made some enemies and because
people you know i work with a lot of
businesses and people this happens in
business where people they want to speak
up they see something that maybe could
be done
better different and of course there's
always a
a particular line that i make look if
someone's doing something that's illegal
immoral or unethical okay we're not
doing that we got it
but a lot of times and i wrote about
this
in leadership strategy and tactics i
called it conform to influence because
when i was in my first
seal platoon i was i wanted to be all
hardcore
and so it was me and i was wearing a
rucksack on the old course and
wearing a rucksack out on the runs and
and i was a new guy
and i thought i was being cool and and
hard and
getting ready for war but my platoon was
kind of looking at me like
you know who do you think you are you're
truly trying to prove hey rambo
and i realized oh i need to be a part of
this team
if i'm going to have influence over them
do i want them to train harder yeah i do
absolutely but if they don't like me if
i'm not part of the team
they're not going to listen to anything
i say as a matter of fact i'm
ostracizing myself
so i know this is a it seems like you
went through this situation where
you know you held up your hand and made
a call i'm gonna go in this direction or
i think we should go in this direction
and
didn't work out the other part of this
is i always say if you're doing the
right things for the right reasons
you'll win in the end but it sometimes
can take a long time
before you you quote win and you might
take some tactical losses along the way
but if you're doing the right things for
the right reasons eventually things
should go your way when you reflect on
on whatever went down at that command
and the way it turned out
what did you learn from it yeah i
learned a lot from it actually uh
and it all i think positively influenced
me over the years
first i didn't make all the right calls
i mean there's no question about it
i could have been a better officer uh
and you know at the end of the day the
commanding officer
has the right to decide who he thinks is
gonna be you know leading his platoons
his squadrons
and and i've never really faulted the co
for making that decision
i realized i could have done things
better the command could have done
things better but to your point
i part of what i learned was i didn't
conform
i think the way that they had hoped i
would conform
and part of it was it just wasn't me uh
it wasn't a good cultural fit for me at
the time
um but but i think you nailed it when
you said you know there are times if
you're going to influence
the people that work with you better to
do it from inside the wire than outside
the wire sort of thing
now again back to the it's got to be
more illegal and ethical
um but but what i also learned was
you know you're going to have these
rough times uh in the teams or anywhere
you go
but but that day i went home and i
remember thinking and i said
i don't know if i got a career left here
um
and uh how long my wife and i have been
married at that point in time
you know five six years something like
that and uh i came home and i said hey
i'm not sure what i should do and she
said look you've never quitted anything
in your life
don't start now and best advice i could
have had and of course you've got to
weather the storm because
fortunately the commanding officer i
mean my paper wasn't good but it wasn't
bad i mean
he didn't crush me in my fitness report
i was picked up by another team right
after that who the
commanding officer kind of gave me a
second chance i made the best
of that second chance but you know i go
to a new team
and of course the guys know you know
the rep the reputation thing if you
don't know in the seal teams and in life
but in the seal teams it's like
multiplied and intensified your
reputation
is so uh powerful and when
i mean there's guys that make a mistake
when they show up as a new guy and
25 years later they retire and their
nickname is still based on the fact that
they did something stupid as a new guy
that everybody knows it that's when you
meet them that's their name
is whatever dumb thing they did when
they were a new guy when they were 18 or
19 years old
well and this was you know so there was
kind of this whisper campaign when i got
to the new team
and and you understand that and you
realize hey
i got to prove them wrong i've got to
prove that i'm a good officer and
and so fortunately soon after i got to
the command i went on a deployment
it was a good deployment uh i did well
at the command i went on to another
command and then you know you begin to
rebuild your reputation and
frankly never looked back after that um
but what it also helped me do was when i
got into command
um and and all of my command tours
thereafter when i saw somebody that made
a mistake when i saw somebody that
screwed up
um you want to find an opportunity if
they're a good officer good enlisted to
give them that second chance
so that they aren't branded with you
know a bad reputation you put them in a
position to be successful to get over
whatever that fault or that failure
might have been
and i was fortunate to have a an officer
named john sandoz who picked me up at
seal team four
took me under his wing and said hey i
remember you from my time at the west
coast and
and let's get back to work uh and again
that uh that kind of quickly got me over
the hump and then uh
yeah you never look back so you know
when you have the opportunity in a
leadership position
uh to help somebody out to give them
that second chance to put them on the
path
to be better than what they were and you
take that opportunity
how freaking crazy obsessive were you to
do a good job when you got the team for
i mean i can't even imagine if i was in
that situation
i was already crazy on trying to do a
good job you know like
you must have been just full bore like
your wife must have said after another
three months she must say maybe you
should quit
there was a lot of that but you also
realized you can't overreact
and and i think when i got in there at
first i would see things people
you know that i thought were sliding me
and initially i can't overreact to it
because i was overly sensitive to it
when
it was just team guys being team guys
you know back to the pt circle you know
you're thinking
was it was there something hidden in
that we and there wasn't yeah
and so you got to kind of get over that
and uh
and find that balance that goes okay
look yeah you're gonna get harassed that
you know that's best part of being in
the teams enjoy the good-natured
harassment
uh and don't take it so personal every
time and
but to your point it probably took me a
while to get over that
i think i had to get past the deployment
uh and then my next job was as the ops
officer at
uh still delivered vehicle team too and
i had a great bunch of guys there
and again everything went well and never
looked back
what did you do for a deployment at team
four so i went down to uh
south america did a united states and uh
had a uh a great platoon and the thing
about it was i mean we just
you know you kind of lived off the land
back then we weren't as sophisticated we
didn't kind of have the money so we
parachuted into colombia
spent uh three weeks in some you know
back part of columbia
where most of the day we were foraging
for food
literally so you know we were looking
for drinkable water
i had to send a couple of guys to go to
the market to get food because we didn't
back then
yes you could have brought sea rats as
we refer to them the mres of today um
but those were heavy you know those were
in big boxes we didn't want to be
carrying that around so
you know a couple guys would be assigned
child duty and while the rest of the
platoon went out and and worked with the
buso tacticos of the colombians and then
we went from there to ecuador to peru to
chile to yeah
brazil i mean it was a great deployment
so you then you did um ops officer sdv
team two right and then from you there
1989 you you're the you're the exo at
steel team one yeah so from
from uh sdv team two i went to pentagon
for two and a half years okay um
and uh you know every operator goes
kicking the screen into an admin job
um but this one actually probably set me
up for
success much more so than i would have
thought because you get into the
pentagon and this was at a time when
again the
the seals we worked for the surface
warfare guys um
and the ship drivers and we worked in
what was called oppo three in the
pentagon but it was there
where all the money that the seals got
for beans bullets bodies buildings you
name it
came through the pentagon so i learned i
was a lieutenant made lieutenant
commander there i learned how to work
the system how to get manpower in a
seal team how to get buildings built how
to get money for more ammunition
none of my contemporaries had that
experience so when i left
um the pentagon and then went off to be
the executive officer at seal team one
uh in 1988 um i mean
as the xo nobody could keep up because
the cia was saying hey can we get some
more bodies here yes sir i know how to
do that
can we get more money to the team yes
sir i know how to do that you know
and uh and so understanding the
resourcing end of it
uh you know made you a good staff
officer now no seal wants to have that
moniker on them you know you're a good
staff officer but at the end of the day
the good staff officers are what allow
the team guys
the operators to have the equipment they
need and the you know the
the money to go do the training and that
sort of thing now by that time as the
as the 80s and the reagan years and the
reagan build-up starts
the money started to come but before
that uh we in the steel team we were
living on a shoestring after vietnam
uh i mean you know you uh you would go
out to nile in california
uh which was our our desert our desert
training area was our only training area
and uh and i think they they paid you
like eight dollars a day
uh and and you were like woohoo eight
dollars a day that's great
uh because a lot of other places you
went you went on permissive tdy
meaning they didn't didn't pay anything
you just went um
we always had a lot of ammunition and
demolition but not much else
what was the billet that you were in up
at the pentagon so i was the assistant
to
the director of what they called op 37
so 37 was the designator for the naval
special warfare actually i'm sure we
called it naval special warfare back
then
that didn't come along until a little
bit later but yeah there was a seal
component
in the pentagon that did all the
resourcing
i know when i came in the military i
thought
like the whole idea that you had to pay
for stuff just didn't even make sense to
me i thought everything was just free
right
hey you need gas you go to the gas thing
at the navy base and they'll give you
the gas you need
didn't even make sense to me that you
had to pay for ammo and that human
being's like
oh you're going to assign people to a
seal team it's just they're just people
they show up there
so that that the the idea that was real
foreign to me when people started
talking about how much this trip is
going to cost
i would be like well we're in the
military what are you talking about
um so that gave you yeah for sure that's
some insight you must have had you were
like a black belt compared to the rest
of these guys running around
yeah and nobody wanted to go to the
pentagon of course and nor had i wanted
to go initially
um but again turned out to be a great
two and a half years because you you
learned the system well and frankly that
served me
throughout as i became a canadian
officer in a commodore uh i understood
how to walk the halls of the pentagon
and how to leverage
uh those resources we needed to get the
job done
yeah you mentioned so far a bunch of
different relationships that you have
had and built and i mean they shine
throughout everything that you write
about it's all about
who you're working with i know i've
worked with this guy in the past and
knew this individual and we
spent time together the the
relationships that you build but
not only in the seal teams but then you
start talking about relationships that
you have
and in the pentagon and who you work
with there and who you know it's
you can't there's no possible way to to
overestimate the
amount of roi you get on having good
relationships with people and treating
them good
relationships you're right it's all
about relationships and particularly
after 9 11
you realized even more so because your
relationships
were the cia with the national security
agency with the national geospatial
agency
with the army navy air force marine
corps with the
the service chiefs when i became the
socom commander i mean
you have to build these relationships
with the combatant commanders with
you know up and down the chain of
command because it's the relationships
that are going to allow you to get the
mission done
and if you have built good relationships
if you haven't burned the bridges
because you got hacked off about
something
those relationships really pay dividends
in combat
i had my uh when i was a task unit
commander my two platoon commanders come
in to me and we're out
we're out at an island and we've got a
bunch of paperwork due to the commanding
officer you know the
serialized inventory and the
qualifications of the various guys and
all this and
they you know the guys come we shouldn't
have to do all this paperwork right now
this is [ __ ]
come on we need we're we're training for
war
and you know they tried to they try to
capitalize on my war-like nature by
telling me you know we're training for
war and i said hey guys we're gonna do
all this paperwork we're getting it
turned in perfectly and we're gonna do
it before anyone else does
because we gotta have a good
relationship with the boss and if the
boss doesn't think i can get paperwork
turned in on time
why is he gonna trust me to go out and
run operations exactly right
um from there you now you go to
to exo seal team one
who's the who is the ceo when you were
there commander tim holden okay
phenomenal officer naval academy
graduate mit hart
a lot like daniel stewart i mean hard as
nails um
tim would pt everybody under the ground
uh just a remarkable officer
unfortunately was killed in a bicycle
accident
several years ago but just a terrific
terrific guy
and you did one um you did one operation
there which was the
the recovery of a navy aircraft that had
crashed in 1948
yeah it was a p2v so think of the p3
variant back then
and uh yeah uh commander holden tim
holden had been sent out as you recall
this was during the kind of the tanker
wars and been sent out to the wynn brown
so i was the acting ceo
as the executive officer and george bush
who had been
i think initially the vice president
then of course became president had had
been petitioned by the families of the
the naval aviators that have been killed
in this crash the plane had never been
found
and and they had been asking for uh the
navy to put on kind of a full court
press try to find the aircraft there had
been some
speculation where it went down um and
this had gone on for years eventually
somebody found the remains but because
it was in such kind of treacherous
condition they they couldn't or
found the what they thought was the
remains of the airplane but couldn't
couldn't get to it so eventually we get
the letter you know the the president uh
wants us to
to go recover the aircraft because it's
at about ten thousand feet that's where
they thought it was
uh and they figured we could do some
high altitude diving uh so as the
executive officer i get tagged to be the
kind of mission commander
and it was a uh a unique experience i i
took a guy named george parkhill who was
uh i think george was probably a chief
or singer chief at the time
he ran the dive locker when they got the
school team one yeah he was the dive
master and that's why i picked george
and a couple of other great guys to go
up there and so we get up to this place
called first tofino and then
we have to take hilo out to the kind of
the middle of nowhere on the outback
and the place where we think the plane
has crashed
is in what i believe to have been kind
of an old volcanic uh
you know uh area i mean it looks like
the inside of a
what you think of as a volcano almost
like diamond head um
and there's a lake in the middle of it
uh where the snow is melted off and
you could only get into this place like
for a month out of the year
because it would it would freeze over
and so this was i think september time
frame
so we get on the ground and there's i
mean the hilo can't even land so we had
to kind of jump off the hilo and kind of
get set up
um but uh we're looking around and
there's clearly no airplane in this
in this bowl we're in but there is uh
off to the area where the sun
doesn't hit so the sun would kind of
make its way around but never kind of
quite got to this area
and as you look there's this kind of the
only thing i can think of to describe is
like a snow tunnel
and it goes up about a thousand plus
feet and it is
you know i mean it's just a uh an area
that's just completely covered with ice
and but we're looking around thinking
that the plane is probably in the water
that's where why we were sent up to get
it
well the next day after we get in there
uh park hill goes over and uh
and starts chipping into this uh this
kind of ice cave
and goes in and i'll be damned there the
plane is it's it is hidden
under this ice cave and has been there
for you know 40 50 years that point in
time of course it is
because the ice would melt and it would
just crush the plane so there's
nothing left but you know tiny pieces
although actually the 50 cal survived
um but so now we have found the remains
of the plane
and uh and again there were some we
eventually bring
uh some of the family out that was fit
enough to to be there
uh we we did manage to find some bone
fragments and we buried those at the
site
but in the in the book i i i tell the
story and
i said you can believe it or not but it
is true and i'm not the only one to have
seen it as we are
kind of burying that uh the remains of
this thing and we
i said a little prayer over this uh this
cross we put up there
and then as i get through saying it
all of a sudden one of the guys turns me
goes hey sir
take a look up there and again if you
can imagine we're in this
bowl and i think it goes up to about 8
000 feet or something like that and and
right above the ridge line
i see what looks like a parachute flare
i'm thinking
is somebody shooting parachute flares uh
you know i'm looking around thinking
well
maybe one of our guys is you know
shooting parachute flares and i
um nobody's shooting carefully shoot
flares and there's one
and there's two three four five six
seven eight
nine and they're kind of hovering up
there and
looking around thinking what in the
world and the guy says uh
hey sir how many of those do you see and
again it's just this kind of
glowing orb and it's just kind of
floating up there and there were nine of
them
and there were nine victims on the plane
and
and it was up there for 10 or 15 minutes
they all kind of hovered up and one by
one
they just kind of went up so i said look
uh you can believe the story or not but
i'm not the only one that saw it and
i've often thought well if somebody was
firing parachute flares please let me
know because
it was kind of one of those surreal
moments uh because you are
out in the outback where there is
nothing out there um
but uh but interestingly enough another
kind of
story like the like the barney brow
story in that um
i get a call from uh you know a good uh
good friend who you would know jeremy
williams and jw says hey sir
got an army buddy uh we were just having
dinner and i was telling him about your
book
and uh uh he's gonna call you when he
gets to san francisco
i said okay so he was flying back to
hawaii and i got a call from this guy
he says hey sir uh jw was telling me
about your
story in your book and so i got a copy
of it
that was my grandfather that died on
that crash
and oh by the way my grandmother is
still alive so i got a hold of the
grandmother
and it was just a great conversation
wonderful lady
um and and you re and i i told her i
said ma'am i
i don't tell you the story i'm telling
you in the book is exactly true
um you know my my hope is uh you know
uh that your husband is in the right
place and uh and this
and and her husband had been a young
petty officer in the navy during world
war ii
gets out of the navy after world war ii
and then
missed the navy so much comes back in
gets assigned up to whidbey island as a
a backender on the this p2v and
unfortunately you know crashes in the
p2v
and like he was 23 years old or
something like that and
but it was just the connections uh have
been interesting
i mean the book gets out there and then
somebody reads it and then makes a
connection
you know six degrees removed sort of
thing
yeah that's uh that whole story is
sounds
it's almost supernatural there's some
other things that you talk about in the
book worth reading
you you so you get done with that and
you do uh
is that when you rolled into being a
task unit commander right so uh
so then this was right before desert
storm uh so when i left the xo back then
the executive officers a lot of times
would go do and be the task unit
commander for a deployed
you know seal platon on an amphibious
ready group so it was uh
again this was 1990
uh summer of 1990 and i'm with com
fibron 5
and so i go off as an o4 as the task
unit commander
and no sooner you know we left in
june i guess and then saddam invades
iraq
in august i think so we were already on
deployment
and we were a full-up amphibious ready
group so we became kind of the go-to
guys as the
rest of the navy was kind of building
the rest of the amphibious ready groups
but we'd already been through the whole
workup so we kind of immediately got
tasked to head out to the gulf
uh had a chance to interdict do uh some
maritime interdiction operations which
were a lot of fun considering
those were kind of the first of their
kind that was the big mish back there
that's right
the the meal the maritime interdiction
operations
those were the what i did those in
what was it 99 well i guess i did some
in the
earl in the mid 90s but yeah those were
real world i got to lock and load my
weapon
uh what else did you guys do for on that
didn't you guys didn't you guys do some
hit some islands or something as well
yep so the uh
so we went out there uh first time
in uh i want to say november this
november december and then
we didn't know whether or not we were
actually going to you know uh
come into kuwait so they sent us back uh
to submit bay for about three weeks
uh not knowing well are we going to you
know
we're gonna send a large force into
kuwait to kick saddam out and
uh so that was all still up in the air
so they said look you guys are the most
experienced
go back and wait so i think we spent
christmas in
subic and then we got the word nope we
think this thing's gonna go so they
sailed us back out
uh i mean we went through the straits of
malacca in the in the straits of hormuz
about half a dozen times so we get out
there into the gulf and
um and yeah so first back in the
november time frame we did the maritime
interdiction operations on some iraqi
tankers
um and then our job was going to be to
prep for the amphibious landing
uh and so we in addition to the fibron 5
they brought
what then later became the largest
amphibious force i think since korea 33
ships
uh looking at doing an amphibious
landing in i think a place called
ashuwaiba
in kuwait with the idea that we would
land the force and then
you know begin to engage with the ground
force and then push
saddam out of kuwait well um it uh
it of course became one of the faints
the idea was uh
we want to hold down saddam's forces so
it kind of became known i think to to
the iraqi army that we were going to
land
a large force at ashuaiba so of course
two divisions came
set down in kuwait to stop us from from
landing well that allowed the ground
forces to kind of sweep around and
so we didn't do the amphibious lane we
did take a couple of islands we took
uh falaka island uh which it was
actually very interesting again
a good lesson for me so falaka uh
had been bombed for like a hundred
straight days or 1200 iraqi officers
our officers enlisted on the falaq
island because it was a kind of a key
position
before you got up into the into the
waterway
and and navy fighters when they would
come back they'd have to dump their
bombs
so for again i like 90 days or something
they were dropping bombs ordinance on
flock island flock island was only about
two inches above the
sea level and it's just flat as it could
be so the iraqis at night would you know
they
dig trenches and they'd hide in the
trenches as we're dropping bombs on
so finally uh when the time came the
iraqis
surrendered uh in falaq and we go we go
pick up these guys
1200 of them and move them from falaca
to the amphibs
before we send them back to like saudi
arabia and then back to kuwait
but interestingly enough with all that
bombing
i think the bombs only killed about five
iraqis so it showed
you know we wonder you know how how did
the germans withstand the naval
bombardment on normandy
and how did the japanese survive it well
the answer is if you dig deep enough
uh even you know a thousand pound bombs
unless they land right on your head
which apparently what happened
uh to a couple of these guys you can
survive this stuff
but also the iraqis uh it was
interesting to see us i was
the colonel uh who accepted their
surrender
uh you know separated the officers from
the enlisted but now i'm you know
i'm on the island for several hours and
i started flying back with some of the
iraqis
and they were hey man i'm from detroit i
i came back to iraq to see my parents
actually you know
there were a lot of these guys that were
american iraqis that had come back and
kind of gotten seconded into the into
the iraqi army and were like yeah i
really didn't want to be here and uh do
you have a cigarette by the way
i don't that's that's pretty
uh awesome experience though for you and
i know that i was a rare guy that
volunteered to do arg platoons
because there was actually missions that
happened
you know the guys that were the the guys
that were in the seal teams that were in
somalia
a bunch of them came off our platoons
and i was like okay if they're if that's
where i got to go
and so i volunteered for arg platoons
but where it really helped me out was
that i was working with i was working
with the marine corps right and we were
you know building relationships with the
marine corps but just understanding look
when you're in a seal platoon
in the 90s you didn't understand
anything about the rest of the military
it was like hey i got a 16-man platoon
we'll take on the world
then i learned oh this is a battalion
this is how this is going to work this
is this is the way we can work together
with them this is the support that we
can give them so
it was very useful and very helpful for
me i was very like i was a calm guy so i
i made all the comms plan and learned
how to how to communicate with all the
different forces it was
very very helpful for me to to do those
i did two arg deployments
and learned a lot about the conventional
forces which was real lucky
um you get done with that and then now
you finally get your
your time in uh in monterey right yeah
finally i think the fifth set of orders
i finally got to monterey so i went up
there for two years and
set up the special operations low
intensity conflict the solar curriculum
uh and then ended up graduating from
that curriculum but also took the time
that that's when i had an opportunity to
write my thesis on the
on the the principles of special
operations or the theory of special
operations
and monterey was a great time because
one i'd i've been deployed for 10 months
on the amphibious ready group and and
frankly been running hard for several
years
and my wife while i was deployed my wife
had a had our third child
so i came back we had my oldest boy had
been born
uh when i was going on my first
deployment
he was born in a week later i go on a
deployment number two some was born in
the philippines in jungle general
uh literally that's what he called a
jungle general and in fact a couple of
years ago
when i was the socom commander we went
back out philippines and i went down to
zamboanga my wife
got a driver from manila to go back to
the subic bay she hadn't been there in
30 some odd years
so i'm down in in zamboanga for a couple
days i i finally come back up to manila
to pick her up and i
get into the hotel room and she goes do
you know
that john was born in a quonset hut
i said yeah she goes i mean it was a
quonset hut
yeah i know i mean that's all we had was
a coincidence and
so i mean jungle general was a series of
quonset huts
and uh and so i said number two son was
joined
i was born there and then we waited
quite a while and and finally
for our third child we we thought hey we
got this all figured out
uh my wife got pregnant i'm gonna go on
a six-month deployment
i'll come back you know i'll have time
to you know get ready for the baby to be
born
and of course my six-month deployment
turns into ten months and i come back
and
and my my daughter's a month old like
hey i think that worked out okay
but uh worked okay out okay for one of
you yeah that's right but then then we
did get up to monterey and uh
and that was a good time so out there is
where you
your thesis became a book right and the
book is called spec ops case studies in
special
operations warfare theory and practice
i'm going to jump into this a little bit
carl von klauskwitz
in his book on war noted the defensive
form of warfare is intrinsically
stronger than the offense
it contributes resisting power the
ability to preserve and protect oneself
thus the defense generally has a
negative aim
that of resisting the enemy's will if we
are to mount an offensive to impose our
will we must develop enough force to
overcome the inherent superiority
of the enemy's defense cosworth's theory
of war states that to
quote defeat stronger the stronger form
of warfare
an army's best weapon is superior
numbers in this sense superiority of
numbers
admittedly is the most important factor
in the outcome of an engagement
so long as it is not so long as is great
enough to counterbalance all
other contributing circumstances it thus
follows
that as many troops as possible should
be brought into the engagement at the
decisive point so you start off with
that which
people always ask me i've covered just
about every
well i've covered a lot of war theory
and i never
cover close words and one of the reasons
i've never covered klaus wits i haven't
yet i've covered a little bit but
is because i like liddell heart better
of course and
and so apparently you feel the same way
um continue on with your book no soldier
would argue the benefit of superior
numbers
but if they were the most important
factor how could 69 german commandos
have defeated a belgian force of 650
soldiers
protected by the largest most extensive
fortress of
its time the fort at eben emal which is
a
special operations paratroopers landing
with gliders on this
and and as you just said 69 german
paratroopers
took on this massive belgian force
and won how can special operations force
that has inferior numbers
and the disadvantage of attacking the
stronger form of warfare gain
superiority over the enemy
to understand this paradox is to
understand special operations
relative superiority relative
superiority is a concept crucial to the
theory of special operations
simply stated relative superiority is a
condition that exists
when an attacking force generally
smaller gains a decisive advantage over
a larger or well-defended enemy
the value of which the concept of
relative superiority lies in its ability
to illustrate
which positive forces influences the
success of a mission
and to show how frick the frictions of
war affect the achievement of the goal
this section will define the three basic
properties of relative superiority
and describe how those properties are
revealed in combat
and then you talk you talk about
relative superiors
achieved at a pivotal moment in the
engagement
once relative superiority is achieved it
must be sustained in order to guarantee
victory
and if relative superiority is lost it
is difficult to regain again
and then you go on to explain what you
already mentioned the six principles of
special operations
simplicity security repetitions surprise
speed and purpose and the book what this
book consists of
is is case studies that that describe
and show how all these things come into
play
so that's you made pretty good time of
your
of your of your session up there in
monterey yeah
you know it was uh to your point you
know you take advantage of the
opportunities you get
i found studying at the postgraduate
school was
yeah i'd been an operator for 15 years
it was it was great
actually now to kind of get an
opportunity to to get intellectually
engaged and there are some phenomenal
faculty and professors up there but when
i when i decided to write a thesis
um i'd read a lot of class what's and
you know klaus kind of talks about the
principles of war and you know
everybody has these ideas of various
principles of war and cosmets point
there is look the defense is always
going to be stronger than the offense
because the defense just has to preserve
and protect
while the offense has to impose its will
upon the enemy so that was the
but but then then if that's true then
why does soft work and so
i went in there initially looking for
the principles of special operations
so uh i i went and visited all these
uh places and talked to all these
commandos and and the
but but i was visiting i was in in
germany
meeting with uh lieutenant vitzig who
was the
the at the time he was the lieutenant
that re led the raid on abana mail
and colin kilrain who was a young
lieutenant at the time who is now a vice
admiral
uh colin kilrain uh was uh stationed
uh up in that conference with the comp
swimmers so colin was going to be my
my translator and so we linked up and
went all over europe interviewing these
guys it was great but we get down to
talk to lieutenant fitzig
and it was hard to find these guys com
because again this said
there there was some sense that because
they had been in the german military was
there some nazi overtones et cetera et
cetera
didn't not the case with lieutenant
vitzig because he had gone on to work in
the west german army and retired as a
colonel
but nonetheless i think there was always
some concern about
you know some of the wartime efforts but
finally colin tracks him down so we go
to visit him
and uh and i'm sitting there for three
hours and i have created this list of
questions for him
and and he's a very stern fellow and and
uh
and was very cautious early on and so as
we're talking
and i'm asking these questions colin is
translating them and
he's answering them short
almost bluntly doesn't seem particularly
happy that i'm there but
he's trying to be gracious and finally
about three hours into it
i turned to colin i said ask the colonel
if he's the one that actually developed
the plan
for how the demolition was going to be
used on the surface of a been a male
and in perfect english he says yes i was
and we continue on in english for the
next hour or so
he'd been vetting me he wanted to find
out whether or not this was a serious uh
but it was the kernel so he says at one
point in time i'm
i'm kind of talking about this he says
so you are trying to develop a theory
here
and at the time i was not i was just
trying to identify principles and i
thought
huh he says i think you are working on a
theory you need to flesh out the theory
and so i went back and spent the next
year thinking okay
how do you take not just the principles
but what is the theory of special
why do special operations work when they
shouldn't work based on kind of
cloudswits and a lot of others
uh and then again the case studies uh
kind of bore out why they work in
certain areas and why they don't
but the but the study of that uh paid
dividends for me after 9 11 because
every single time i reviewed a mission
and i figured at one point in time that
i had
i had touched about 10 000 missions over
the course of
my time as the deputy commander jsok and
the jsoc commander
where you know you're either commanding
them
you're overseeing them or you're
reviewing them because you know every
every concept of operation
early on had to come to a general
officer so i would review every concept
of operation as well
and i always ask myself okay we're
making this too hard is it is it a
simple plan
carefully concealed repeatedly rehearsed
and executed with surprise
speed and purpose and that was that was
the essence of this
recognizing that the frictions of war
chance and uncertainty [ __ ] happens is
gonna try to knock your plan
off it's this kind of apex that it's on
and the only thing that's going to keep
it upright
is the courage and the boldness and the
perseverance of the men that are
that are fighting to keep this plan
upright and
and as i would think through all of
these concepts when i'd see it a con up
i'd say
now we're making this too complicated
guys make it make it easier make it
simpler
i mean i was always trying to get to the
simplest approach
you couldn't always get there but you
wanted to do that because you realized
the
simpler it was the less chance uh
the the less risk you were going to have
the less chance that things could go
wrong
and that was just always you know in the
back of my mind then of course the bin
laden raid comes along
uh and we we adhered to the
the thesis the theory as closely as we
could i said look we're going to flesh
all of this out
we're going to keep this plan and we're
going to go from point a to point b in a
helicopter
get on the ground just like we do you
know we've done
thousands of times before we're not
gonna make it complicated
we'll get the bad guy we'll put him on a
helicopter and take him home
that's it oh by the way now we're gonna
repeat this thing we're gonna rehearse
rehearse rehearse rehearse
we're gonna keep it uh confidential so
nobody else knows about it
and then when the day comes through the
mission we will have surprise
speed and god knows we had purpose
um so you know that was just the way i
attended after my time in monterey
tended to look at every single mission
we did
you get done with monterey and then
what's what's next
so after monterey i went back down to
naval special warfare command
for about a year waiting to take command
and i was i was training officer down
there for a year just an admin position
holding a holding position if you will
until i took command of seal team three
is that when you did the project where
you're kind of looking at the next
generation of warfare
so uh in between that was really when i
was the chief of staff so i left sale
team three
and then became the chief of staff at
group one uh which
uh for your listeners oversees all the
seal teams on the on the west coast
and that's when we really began to
develop this idea of thinking
back to le del hart i mean it really was
why do we have to do things the way we
have always done them because even up
till
you know 1998 we were still doing the
way
things the way we had done in vietnam
even even
the guys on the elite east coast seal
teams
hadn't developed too much beyond kind of
the standard seal
platoon size and by the way nobody else
gets in the platoon but a platoon guy
you got to have gone through buds and it
was like what if you're going to tap
into some wire or something
where is the pencil neck geek guide
you're going to bring level sorry we
can't bring him along because he doesn't
know how to ride in the zodiac
put two put two life jackets on him
stick him in the zodiac because you're
bringing this guy along
and then of course admiral olsen had
taken over war com when i became the
commodore
and he'd seen things work on the east
coast and so he really wanted to take a
look at naval special warfare even more
broadly
so how do we have sniper elements well
back in the day when i came in
the sniper was in your platoon you know
the radio man was in your platoon
everything was inside the platoon
organization well then we began to say
hey yeah but
you're breachers well that that's what
one of the guys the platoon was the
designated preacher one of the guys in
between was the automatic website one of
the guy in platoon was a
was the sniper well why don't we take
guys that do a lot of sniper work and
make them the world-class snipers and
then world-class preachers
that that evolved then all of a sudden
911 hits and it went on steroids
before i i jumped over a part when you
were ceo of seal team three
uh one thing i used to tell guys all the
time was if we were doing an off if
we're doing a
a water op i'd say hey if you're in the
water it's a real world op
because if you're in the water you can
die period
and you about died about that i'd steal
team three
as the as the commanding officer up in
was it morro bay
bay capsized in a rib yeah
that was not a good day except i came
out of it live so maybe it was a good
day
yeah we went up there it was one of the
platoon was doing their final exercise
before deploying
and as you know the commanding officer
generally comes up for the ftx the final
training exercise
uh we'd gone up tomorrow bay
myself and the command master chief um
and
the platoon was still doing some
training they were going to do the ftx i
think the following day
and uh the there had been a storm off
the coast so
morro bay's got this thing that looks a
little bit like the rock of gibraltar
kind of right in the middle of morro bay
and but what it does is it funnels the
waves
so the storm surge off the coast had
created these huge waves breaking coming
into morro bay
well there was a place inside morra bay
where the seals were training so they
were kind of in their zodiacs doing
their regular training
but i noticed as i was getting out to go
with the platoon that i saw two
ribs out there they didn't belong to me
they belong to the special boat unit
but i'm i'm kind of looking thinking wtf
what are these guys plan on doing
because i'm looking at 20 foot waves
breaking here
and uh so i'm i'm with one of the seals
i said
run me out to that that boat out there
so they zip me out there and they
and i get on the rib and i'm talking to
a young lieutenant surface warfare
officer
i said so what's plan here son
and he says uh i said we're gonna we're
gonna go out through the waves i said
you're gonna go through those ways sir
we've got a plan i've got my uh my
senior chief he's on the jetty he's
timing the waves
we're actually not going to go straight
out through them we're going to kind of
cut around near the jetty just as it's
breaking
and by the way all my guys are trained
in kodiak you know we can do this
uh okay well give me a life jacket i'll
go with you
and of course there are two seals in the
back of the boat
uh tom rainville and ginopalusa
and uh so gino who you may know he's got
quite the sense of humor he said hey sir
come on let's go and he said uh you know
i didn't have a dry suit on the water
temperature was in the 50s and then he
said yeah if we tip you know you're
gonna get awful cold i said well then
don't capsize the boat
so we're in the back three of us are
three seals are kind of in the back of
the boat in the bolster seats back there
and
and you know we're all kind of timing
the waves as team guys team to do and
frank the waves are getting kind of
bigger and bigger
and all of a sudden the coxswain guns it
whoa and he had straight for the wave
and
i mean we hit this first wave we go
straight up the first wave about 30
knots
and i literally am counting like you do
when you jump out on a static line i go
1 000 2 000 3 000 4 000
bam we hit in between the the first and
the second wave
well the the bauman he goes he goes
flying off
uh he's lost one of the engines now he
does the right thing the coxswain swings
the boat around because we got no choice
now so
he guns it to try to beat the second
wave well the second wave you know his
waves tend to get bigger and bigger
second wave is probably 30 some odd feet
and and he hits it again
and we hit it full speed and we go up in
the air and this time i am
i literally count to 5 thousand one
thousand two thousand
three thousand four thousand five
thousand we hit it's like holy [ __ ]
hit the boat cracks guys are thrown out
and
now all of a sudden the wave of the day
comes you know
so the boat is facing the scene but now
we got no power
and that third wave just lifts that boat
up and i can remember seeing it as the
boats get lifted up
and and you know there's water coming
over the 33-foot boat
and there's another you know eight foot
of water coming over the top of the
thing and it just
bang throws us right on the back well
i'm underneath the boat and uh and i'm
tangled up in shot line and you know
shot line is this kind of very thin
nylon line it's wrapped around my neck
i've got somebody's weapon is wrapped
around me and i am
i mean i am completely tangled
underneath this rib
and uh again much like you know times
that you have in the teams
most of the times you can you can get
your way out of these things
and uh and so i'm under the boat and i'm
i'm trying to extricate myself from this
thing but it's choking me
and i'm i'm losing air and i remember
thinking to myself
so this is a this is how it's going to
end well i mean
all this time and i'm going to die under
this damn boat
and i remember saying to myself well i'm
never going to see
george ann bill john or kelly again my
wife and three kids
and and as i am struggling again to this
day
and i actually i use the word in the
book miraculously
i'm untangled that should never have
happened i mean i was so
wrapped up in shotline in somebody's
sling
in the bolster seat things and all of a
sudden i'm
i'm loose and i shoot to the surface um
and uh well now i'm in the second set of
waves coming again
and i'm thinking oh i'm not going to
make this and there's two seals who had
seen this uh
seen the boat flip over they're in a
zodiac in their udt swim trunks
uh and they come hauling ass out of
nowhere and they're yelling at me
skipper skipper
and i can hear him and i'm thinking you
better get here fast cause i'm not gonna
survive this next wave
and they come i don't even get in the
boat they the guy does a literal u-turn
you know slide and turn
i grabbed the side of the the sponson
there hang on
and i can remember the prop is hitting
my jungle boots that i've got on yeah
and they pulled me out of the wave just
before it crashes over the top of me
and they had pulled tom rain another
group had pulled tom rainville out
uh those four guys ended up receiving
the navy marine corps life-saving medal
uh for saving my ass uh
and toms as well but back to the second
chances i mean it was once again
uh that could have been the end of my
career
um and and you know there were people
that thought highly enough and then they
went back
i mean they did the investigation
everybody we talked through everything
and the the teams to their credit when
they did the investigation said
you know um this is what we expect
of our operators the lieutenant who was
the
the surface warfare officer i mean we
expect them to push the envelope you
know
this is and a lot of times you're going
to have these expectations guys going to
push the envelope it's not always going
to work out well
uh so to the credit of you know
the admiral and the commodore uh we all
from a career standpoint
survived it fast forward again about uh
i don't know
20 some odd years after the book comes
out i get an email
and uh and a guy says uh sir you know
this is so and so
lieutenant jones of course i didn't name
the name the young lieutenant
uh he said that i won't go into too much
details but he said
i love the story it's exactly how i
remembered it and just wanted to
reconnect with you and say thanks for
everything and
and and he had uh again because he he
had been the boat oh i see and you know
by by navy regs the boto ic actually is
the guy responsible but i the thing that
i admired about this young man is
so he loses the boat and you know
he's got to see i mean one he he does
the right thing he makes sure he's got a
head count on guys
he gets guys out he gets a medevac to
the hospital um
and he takes immediate charge of the
situation uh
gets the boat off the bottom does
everything right
after the disaster and you've seen it
before sometimes
guys have a disaster like that and they
just they're crushed by it
and uh and they can't think and they
can't operate and they can't take
command
this young lieutenant did exactly what
he was supposed to do i mean sometimes
bad things happen
uh and and then you gotta kind of you
gotta man up and get the job done and he
did and
and i think the investigation board saw
that and gave him another opportunity
you're uh you know like i look at your
life and i think you know he's you know
really had some good luck in his life
but also reading your book i think
damn because the one of the next
stories in your career was you basically
got drawn and quartered by your
parachutes
which i i you had a parachute
so you take over the you take over the
what's called naval special warfare
group one which is the person that's in
charge of
all the seal teams on the west coast and
all their training
manning and equipping and and overseeing
and giving them guidance
and you go out on a parachute jump for
whatever reason because that's what we
do
and you you you about got drawn and
quartered from the story
it sounds like you about got ripped in
half that's about right
yeah so this was i mean routine
parachute jump and and i'm not a good
jumper
i'm not a good free faller but you know
it's something you got to do
so we go out launched out of north
island on a c-130 and
get up to about 13 000 feet and it's
gonna be again a routine jump
ramp comes down and it's i mean it's one
of these kind of chamber of commerce
days here in
you know southern california not a cloud
in the sky i remember i mean you can see
mexico you can see the pacific ocean you
see the strand and it's like ah that's a
beautiful day
and i'm i don't know fourth in the line
of march so to speaking
so the guys go out and trump master
gives me a call i go out behind these
guys and and i'm falling flat and stable
i'm looking good
and there's two guys off to my left and
one guy off to my right
and i'm watching this guy off to my
right and he's starting to kind of drift
underneath me
and i'm i'm kind of watching but then he
stabilized next thing i know the guy to
my left is right underneath me
and i check my altimeter it's too late
it's about 500 feet he pulls his
parachute
and and in relative terms course i'm
moving at about 120 miles an hour and
he's stopped
uh i can't get out of the way and i hit
his parachute and it's kind of like
hitting an airbag i would assume
and so it dazes me and now i'm spinning
out of control
as you know what i should have done is
gotten stable again
uh look check my altimeter pulled my
ripcord but
you know things being what they were i'm
spending i'm dazed i'm like hey
i just know i gotta reach for my ripcord
or this isn't gonna end well
so i reach for my rip cord pull it while
i'm in a head down attitude spinning
pilot chute comes out wraps around one
leg the riser comes out
wraps around another leg now i'm
completely tangled up in the parachute i
remember thinking myself
yeah this doesn't look so good so you
know you're i'm sitting here trying to
get my way out of the parachute
or at least get get the damn thing to
open well the good news is
it opens the bad news is when a
parachute opens you know
it blossoms so one riser went one way
one went the other way and it snapped my
pelvis in two uh broke it by about four
or five inches fractured my back ripped
the muscles out of my
stomach that's attached to the the bony
part of your pelvis and ripped the
muscles out of the legs and i end up
about
about two miles from the drop zone now
i'm always quick to point out like
this kind of injury pales in comparison
to what we saw in iraq what we saw in
afghanistan
um and and the lessons you know from the
jump were
not so much about the accident but it
was really more about the fact that uh
you know at the time as you pointed out
i'm the commodore i mean i'm
one of the senior guys on the west coast
i've been in in the business for 20 some
odd years
i'd had a lot of near-death experiences
i was pretty savvy i thought i was
invincible sort of thing
and the next thing you know you know
you're in in the er in the hospital and
and you're laid up and you realize it
takes a whole lot of people
to get you back up going again my wife
became my nurse because once i got out
of the hospital you know you've got to
get shots to make sure you don't
your blood doesn't clot admiral eric
olson made sure i was able to stay in
the navy and back then
that was touch and go because uh you
know you pretty serious
accident oh by the way you're a navy
seal what good are you gonna do if you
can't walk and you can't run and and
team guys being team guys they came by
gave me the right amount of harassment
the right amount of encouragement um
and it really did take a lot of people
to kind of get me up and going again
and and it really was about just this
remarkable
um you know group of folks that we are
you know honored to be part of and
and how they took care of me right about
time i needed it and of course that was
what july 2001
it was yeah so i was i was laid up about
and then of course uh 9 11 happens
and i'm actually kind of recuperating in
my house uh
and we we'd wheeled a hospital bed uh
into my house there in coronado and
naval at the naval base
uh when 911 was happening and uh
and about a a month or so later
i got called to go to the white house um
and wayne downing
and for our listeners he was a retired
four-star
general who would run u.s special
operations command he got asked by
president bush to be in charge of the
office of combating terrorism
which was had been newly established
after 9 11. and downey gets a hold of me
and says hey i'd like you to come work
for me
and he knew i'd been in the accident and
of course at that point i mean i can't
go back to an operational team
as much as i wanted to and i thought
well you know this will
maybe give me a chance to heal and while
i got the white house didn't have any
time doing any rehab you know you just
went right to work
um but i had to park on what was called
the ellipse which was outside the white
house
it was about you know 600 half half a
mile maybe into
into the white house every day and that
became my pt was
getting out of the car and going man
that's a long way to walk you know
but little by little your body heals and
get back to work
so now you're and this is a he said
something that reminded me so i worked
for admiral mcguire
i was his aide not not at this time but
one thing that he had gotten when
september 11th happened he was working
acquisitions at the pentagon or
something like that and i
he he told me you know his attitude was
okay
not i want to go to a team i want to
deploy which is what every team guy
thinks
but he just said you know okay well this
is my foxhole right acquisitions
i'm gonna get money for the teams that's
what i'm gonna do and that was sort of
the same
attitude that it looked like you had it
was like okay this is what i'm gonna do
well i'm
gonna do it to the best of my ability
you you you do talk about
um there's there's a hostage situation
was it martin and grot
yeah yeah martin and gracia barnum well
what was interesting
and you know get the book it's it's it's
fascinating how you put that together
but
one thing that i found interesting about
and it's a good lesson learned for
people is
it was something that was kind of on the
you know on the back burner and people
weren't focused on it and here you had
two americans that were being held
hostage
and like i said it was on the back
burner and you
sort of became a champion for hey we
need to do something about this
and that had a huge impact and
eventually you know a rescue mission
was undertaken um unfortunately the
husband was
was killed but the wife survived and but
one person can make a huge difference
and and you can be you can be a champion
for a cause and have a real impact
which is and you know it's not like you
were the senior guy there or anything
like that but
you you grabbed onto this cause you knew
it was the right thing to do
and let it i thought that was a that's a
powerful thing to think about
well particularly you know i was in the
white house so you're
you are close to the uh you know the
decision makers on these things
and and i realized i did have an opt-in
now i'm a navy captain so i'm fairly
senior
at the time uh but when the barnums had
been held hostage for six or seven
months before i even arrived there
and i was stunned frankly that we the
united states
it's not that we weren't doing anything
but i didn't think we were doing enough
and you know having been in that kind of
hostage rescue business i knew what was
the art of the possible um and so there
was a thing called the hostage
subcommittee which by virtue of my
position i was in charge of it it was an
interagency committee
but to your point jaco yeah you have an
opportunity
no matter where you are in the chain of
command you can make a difference uh
and i was fortunate enough to be able to
get in and brief president bush and to
you know have the ear of uh dr county
rice who was the national security
adviser and ambassadors
from that perch in the white house uh to
be able to try to orchestrate
something on behalf of the barnums and
uh
and so it was uh it was pretty
fulfilling to
again we were we were sorry we couldn't
uh you know
get martin rescued but uh i remember i
i'd never
never met gracia but uh several months
after
uh after she had been rescued i was just
sitting in my cubicle there in the white
house and the phone rang
and uh and she was on the other end and
uh
you know thanking me and it's like you
don't need to thank me
i mean this is you know i'm sorry we
couldn't rescue your husband she was
just she's a remarkable
woman you know just uh her faith
sustained her through
you know that year and a half in the
jungle um
but uh but yeah the best thing about
working in the white house was
almost like the issue with the pentagon
and this really did serve me well
because
two years in the white house now i knew
how the white house worked
and so when i became a deputy jsoc
commander and then the jsoc commander
now you know how to get decisions made
you know what uh what the interagency
process works
it looks like you know who all the
players are and in fact most of the
players a lot of a lot of the players
that i had served with on the national
security council staff then
a couple of years later they're they're
somebody else important uh and so you
can
back to those relationships you can
leverage those relationships in a
positive fashion um
so understanding how the white house
worked and also the great relationships
i had built
served me well uh in a number of my
commands
when in between being the deputy json
commander
and leaving the white house is that did
you go to soccer europe so you did a
tour at soccer was that like your
standard two-year tour
it was two-year tour uh but i was
fortunate at the time i had a great
army kernel of work for me named stu
braden and stu came to me with this idea
that we needed to stand up a nato
special operations force well the folks
in nato
the bureaucrats did not want to do that
but stu understood how to make this
happen and once again
i was fortunate general jim jones was
the eucom commander the sack year
commander at the time
we pitched the uh
the plan to him and he supported it and
as a result we
were able to stand up in 2006 the nato
special operations force
that today has got 22 24 countries that
are part of nato soft
and of course they deployed with us
overseas in afghanistan and
continue to be a great partner um and a
lot of that credit goes right back to
stu braden and the great work he did
from there you do you go to jsoc
um you take over as the deputy commander
and
i think uh you
you you throw out um in c stories you
give an example which i think is a
well it's it's a pretty important story
there's a mission going on
you're in the uh you're in the talk the
tactical operation center
and here we go i'm gonna go to the book
this is from c stories unbeknownst
to me lieutenant colonel bill coltrip
that's right
the sea squadron commander and colonel
jim hickey from 1st brigade 4th infantry
division had maneuvered farther up the
dirt road from
wolverine 1 which was one target to
another small house
designated wolverine 2. as i watched the
isr
feed from the west cam and listened to
the radios the visual and verbal
didn't match up wolverine 1 appeared
reasonably quiet
but the radio calls from cole trip
sounded like they were moving rapidly on
a target
it sounds like they're on target lee i
don't see any movement outside the house
i motioned to the jock non-commissioned
officer who sat at the end of the
long wooden table that made a horseshoe
around the isr screen
so you're sitting there watching this
thing unfold the isrs what's what's
the feed that's coming from the aircraft
overhead he was also on the headset
seeing what i was seeing which was
nothing
i raised my hands in the universal sign
of wtf
and he shrugged and called back isr is
on the target i don't know where the
squadron is sir
i hated to call the squadron in the
middle of an operation
and that's an important point um you
know from a
from from my perspective you know i was
a platoon commander an assault force
commander and a platoon and then a task
new commander
and the fact that you weren't jumping on
there hey where are you at what's going
on what's going on
is is i'd say if you've got a boss
you've got at least a 50
chance of a boss that wants to know
exactly where you are at all time and
it's not fun
and it doesn't help and so here you are
you say i hated to call the squad in the
middle of an operation it's the last
thing any tactical guy on the ground
wants a call from his boss
sitting warm and comfortable in a jock
50 miles away from the action
still it was our responsibility to
manage the quick reaction force and the
medical evacuation if something went
wrong on target
that was hard to do if you didn't have
good situational awareness of the
mission
and the truth was i was curious as to
whether this new lead was panning out so
they were tracking a lead
somewh somewhat reluctantly i pushed the
talk i pushed the talk button and
reached out to coltrip
bill are you on target yes sir culture
responded somewhat excitedly
we don't see you on isr there was a
pause on coltrip's end
sir we are on wolverine2 just down the
road from the original target
and we have jackpot jackpot jackpot
jackpot was the code word meaning they
had captured the objective
at first i assumed coltrip meant case is
that who you were looking for
but suddenly it occurred to me that the
tone of culture's voice indicated
something more
significant jackpot do you mean little
jackpot
or big jackpot big jackpot culture of
answered
and going um as this goes forward
big jackpot was salaam right so these
guys had just captured
saddam um and i was actually i was in
iraq at the time
and and so we had found out i think we
had found out we found out really
quickly one of the guys that we were
working on the oga guys we were working
out
with was one of the early um
interrogators on him and come down yeah
we got him so as much as
i know you were trying to keep it secret
there was
uh it didn't stay strong
stay secret very long i know there's a
there's uh before we jump in a little
bit about saddam so
when you when you were running that
earlier i mentioned you were running
this
project of like looking at the future of
warfare and what we could do and i was
part of that
so i was and there was like five of us
and you were basically taking us and
sending us to all these
uh very cool probably some of the best
schools i ever went to i went to lock
picking and car stealing and
just all these really cool stool uh uh
schools to get us prepared to do like
you said operations from a totally
different perspective
and i remember i i sat through your
brief a couple times
and you would brief you know some senior
officers and you'd say hey listen
in the sealed teams we do direct action
but we have tea lambs now
and so do we really need to do direction
or are we really going to have to do
direct action missions
when we've got telams and we've got
another thing we do is
special reconnaissance well are we
really going to do need to do special
reconnaissance when we've got satellites
and
and we've got you know uav capabilities
that are coming on board
and and you know i remember like i said
i was a young guy and thinking okay well
i need to i need to transfer to this new
format we're not going to do direct
action anymore
i think the next time i saw you i was in
baghdad you came down to camp jenny
posey where we were
we were i was jocked up literally about
to go out on my
whatever 50th or whatever direct action
mission
and and uh i thought it was funny i kind
of smiled to myself said well looks like
we're still doing it looks like we're
still doing it sir um
but but this this mission got saddam and
then
amen you do a it's a very interesting
perspective i mean how
how how crazy is it to sit here and talk
to you
you were interacting with saddam when he
got captured
and you detailed in the book but i mean
just some some high level thoughts what
was that like deal detailing with this
freaking
horrible horrible sadistic person
yeah it was very interesting because the
um you know
when we first captured him i mean he was
pompous he was arrogant
uh when uh when when bill called back
when bill culture called back and said
hey we got big jackpot good to your
point you had asked about case so case
was the guy we were
the facilitator so we were trying to get
the facilitator who we thought was going
to lead us to saddam
well they had gotten case and then case
it had kind of pointed them towards
saddam and they opened the spider hole
you've seen the picture
saddam's in there so they bring saddam
back to crit
and and i'm i'm down in baghdad and um
and so now we had a plan okay what do
you do if you get saddam well i had to
call
general abzade who was the centcom
commander i called john mccrystal who
was my boss back in
tampa and i had to make plans to well we
want to we want to verify that saddam so
i needed to get
dna sent to you know the lab and fbi lab
and all that sort of thing
but uh but as all this is happening
um uh the uh the jtf commander
um general rick sanchez i get the word
joel sanchez is outside the jock i was
like
what i mean he was the big guy in the
rack time three star at the time
and uh so we'll bring him on in so
sanchez comes in sits
down beside me and says uh bill
understand you got to saddam i said hey
sir
i do not know that yet uh yeah i'm not
going to call jackpot until i can
see it until we can verify it you know
how this goes you know there are a lot
of times
we had captured guys who we thought had
the right name the cunhas were different
people were different you call jackpot
then you're embarrassed you know 24
hours later when it's not the right guy
and he says hey no i mean i i heard
through uh you know
through oga that that you got him i said
well sir he'll be down here in 30
minutes
you can see for yourself i think we both
just spotted the leak huh
well so uh so the uh
about 30 minutes later the helo arrives
well uh i mean i'm busy making phone
calls so i turn to my
chief of staff who i call him i think
captain lee at his request
um and i said hey go over there you've
got to come back and
and i'm trusting you tell me whether you
think it's saddam or not so he
and general sanchez go over there and he
comes back a few minutes later he goes
sir it's saddam and said okay so now i'm
calling about and doing my sort of thing
well about uh you know half an hour
later i i go back over there
and uh i remember talking to sanchez it
was kind of one of those funny moments
so saddam has this big beard
and uh and i realized we got to get him
cleaned up because we're going to have
this kind of press release and
everything
and frankly it looked like saddam even
with a big beard i mean he's got this
bulbous nose and everything
but i figured well let's get him cleaned
up so no iraqis can say it's not saddam
so i turned to one of the guys that said
okay let's get him shaved
and get him cleaned up and then we'll
take a picture and then we'll be able to
compare the yeah
so as i'm saying sanchez turns to me
says i don't know bill
do we have the authority to shave him i
said sir
we had the authority to kill him if he
was you know if he was trying to get us
i think we got the authority to shave we
both kind of laughed
i really liked rick sanchez he was a
good guy um
so we so i go off make some more phone
calls i come back assuming that what had
happened was
some ranger or somebody had had gotten
the shears and was kind of clean and
said
why come back saddam's got a pair of
scissors in his hand and he's clipping
his own beard i'm like
no let me have those scissors yeah just
yeah pull those away and he's like
well i was told to get cleaned up but
but the next
the next day was the day when you you
recall the press conference uh
where the ambassador and joel sanchez
say we got him well they hadn't seen him
yet
uh sanchez had seen him but the
ambassador hadn't seen him yet so they
fly out to uh
to our place there in baghdad and go to
to see saddam and they brought some of
the iraqi leaders with them and again
saddam i've you know i've got him now in
a jumpsuit and he's sitting on a cot
but when they when the iraqi leaders
came into the room small
room about this size actually i mean
they are yelling at him
they're spitting at him and he's got
this look on his face like
boys i'm still in charge here sit down
any kind of motions to him you guys just
sit down don't you know who i am and i'm
looking thinking
wow he is he still thinks he's in charge
he's about to find out he's no longer in
charge you know so uh
i didn't really want to bring those guys
in because i knew this would happen it
would just bolster his ego
so after uh after they left i talked to
sanchez and dr ambassador i said
sir that's it i don't want anybody else
visiting him
i am responsible for him now uh i mean
and
called general lab's eight he will tell
you i'm responsible for him so here's
what i'm telling you
nobody else visits him uh we will you
know i will take good care of him
but i don't want him you know feeling
like he's somebody important over the
next 30 days i held on to him
and in the room i had a an officer and a
a security guy and a and a medic or a
doctor at
all times with him because he was 67
years old he had all sorts of health
problems um but it was interesting to
watch
as as the days and weeks went on and he
no longer had his
you know palaces and he no longer had
his generals he no longer had his
handmaidens
he really just became a pathetic old man
um
and uh and every time i'd come in every
i'd go check on him every day
he'd always stand up to want to talk to
me i would say
no and i wouldn't talk to him and it
made him mad and he would talk to the
rangers and the
and the doc and i told him i said i
don't want anybody
saying a word to him um and he would
always ask about el jefe
yeah yeah el jefe and of course i came
in i made sure my stars weren't on my
name tag wasn't on
but he knew who i was yeah i mean just
by yeah
so 30 days into it it was time to move
him
and i was really hoping that by this
time you know the insurgency had really
had kind of blossomed he didn't know
that of course um and i thought well
let's see if i can get him to
tell the insurgents to stand down so we
had a plan
uh brought my translator in and of
course i knew what his answers would be
but i figured
i got nothing to lose here so i sat down
with him and i said
look you know the kind of the war is
over here the americans have come in
we've
and he just kind of nodded and i said
but your people are still dying
and you know you can do one of two
things you can become benito mussolini
and be the petty dictator or you can do
right by your country now
it's not going to end well for you you
got to know that but
tell them to lay down their arms so so
we're not killing any more iraqis
and i knew he'd ask me the question that
i thought he would ask he said
if it was you would you do it and
uh and i said look you know if it was
for the best part of my country
i'd do what it took to save my country
and he looks at me goes
i don't think so he in arabic but it was
true i knew what he meant
and then i said to him i said okay
you're not going to see me again we're
moving you and he was like
because we've been taking pretty good
care of him and he was like
oh this is not a good idea and so then
he starts to get a little talkative i
said
time's done and so that night
we undercover darkness we moved him to
some military police and they held on to
him until the
trial but watching his again watching
him
and his behavior and how it changed when
he no longer felt he was
in a position of power it was okay i
think important to realize
you know that that's what you do you
know you're booked back on bullies you
know at the end of the day
you stand up to the bullies and if all
they had was the trappings
around them they're they're not the kind
of people
that are going to be able to stand up to
you for very long and you know he was a
function of
the generals that supported him and all
of the trappings and when you took that
away
it was just a a bully
a sadistic maniacal uh
evil evil just evil pure evil
so you you you get saddam and
did you think the war was going to be
over at that point
no because by that point we'd seen the
insurgency begin to build
uh as you recall you know i got there in
october of 03 and it was interesting
when i got there the guy i was relieving
it was an air force one star who was the
deputy at jsoc time
um i'm getting there thinking hot dang
that you know
i finally got to get in uh get in the
war and he says
hey look i said you know some great
there's some great restaurants in
downtown baghdad
you know if you uh you know you get a
break go down there's this place to get
some swarm i'm like
i'm sorry what he goes oh yeah i said
man the war's over
and we just got to get saddam but i mean
everything's kind of over now
i was like damn and then
a couple weeks later route irish blows
up and uh and as you know route irish
never changed after that then we started
getting guys ambushed
uh and again this was uh the transition
period of the war
so by time we got saddam in december uh
the insurgency was kind of uh
you know it was it was moving pretty
strong by then so we knew that
it wasn't going to be over anytime soon
but so i was there too at that time
the last op that i did well we did a
couple more but the last big op that i
did
was going after yakubi which was um
sodders one of sodor's lieutenants and
that
that really made things bad really
quickly um
so you you're the you're the deputy at
jsoc
and how how are you just doing like a
port and starboard in iraq
yeah since afghanistan so uh
of course at this point in time so this
is 2003 for me
uh you know we we'd gone into
afghanistan uh kicked the taliban out
put karzai in and then afghanistan was
kind of for a long time there
it was the other theater that we didn't
have much presence there the only soft
presence
was a kind of a half a seal squadron at
the time
uh and and probably some reserve green
berets from uh
from the 20th and 19th group
everybody else was in was in iraq um and
so we go to iraq but then uh in late
2003 john labs 8 says hey look we need
to we need to pick up the pace in
afghanistan a little concerned about the
taliban resurgence etc so what we would
do is
we i would go kind of uh over to theater
and in a you know four or five six
months sort of pump and
and i'd spend a couple of months in iraq
and then i go to afghanistan then i'd
come back to iraq and go to afghanistan
so i would bounce back and forth uh on
the plane
uh you know fly through iud stop there
and then go to afghanistan
spent a couple of weeks there kind of
managing that pop back to iraq and so it
was just kind of back and forth
and it was supposed to be generally
three months on three months off rarely
ended up being that uh
when i was a deputy it'd be you know
four or five months
back for a couple months back out and so
we just kind of flip-flop back and forth
um and at some point in time joel
mcchrystal kind of came over
and uh and really began to focus on iraq
and then
moved me to afghanistan and so myself
and the other deputy then kind of began
to rotate more and more in afghanistan
um but that that took a while
when did you take over as uh commander
jsoc uh 2008
then did you spend start spending more
time in iraq oh yeah
so uh yeah i remember at the time uh
we had developed the capability um to
really be able to kind of command and
control remotely at that point time we
built up the
the jock in in fort bragg to be in a
position where the isr was good enough
and you could have stayed
as the commander you could have stayed
in fort bragg you know let the kernels
and maybe the one stars kind of run
things but you know there's no way that
was going to happen
i mean you got to be forward if you're
going to command um
so yeah i mean a week or so after i took
command i went out to iraq and then
settled down there for six months seven
months i don't remember what it was
and then periodically i'd bounce over to
afghanistan just to
kind of keep things moving over there
and then in 2009 by this time john
petraeus had taken
over centcom and uh and he said hey look
yeah we
we really need to have you the jsoc
commander shift your flag
to to afghanistan so uh
so then i i would say prior to that it
was probably three quarters of my time
in iraq
a quarter in afghanistan 2009 comes
it just reversed then i you know three
quarters of my time in afghanistan about
a quarter of my time in iraq
you gotta you gotta section and see
stories that um i think
i'm not going to say there's a typical
mission but i mean there's a little bit
of a typical mission it's what you
mentioned already you know you do
something over and over again
repetitively and i thought this was a
this one
pretty pretty concise little quote
typical mission
going to the book in a cloud of dust the
helos lifted off from an airfield in
western iraq and within minutes we're in
a tight formation screaming across the
desert just 50 feet off the ground two
minutes later the next
the next call came crossing the border a
drone flying high overhead
captured captured the scene as the four
helos crested a large berm
separating iraq from syria it was broad
daylight and there was no hiding from
view if the syrian air defense detected
helos either visually or on radar
they would immediately open fire with
surface-to-air missiles or anti-aircraft
guns the syrians were our allies
but not our friends one minute to
touchdown
from above the two blackhawk gunships
took the lead and immediately began to
separate one taking the north side
of gadia's compound the other the south
they would provide gunfire support
for the assaulters the view from the
drone shifted away from the approaching
helos
and on to the compound in the large
courtyard
seven men hearing the noise of the
inbound helos began to run excitingly
looking for cover grabbing their guns
ready to fight on screen
roger votel responded watching as the
helos came into view
barely missing the outside wall the lead
helo flared its nose arching upward tail
rotor down as it stopped in midair and
landed hard on the ground inside the
courtyard
shots fired shots fired came the
familiar refrain
the operators poured out of the first
helo and immediately were engaged by
gadia and his men
the next helo was seconds behind
executing the same aerial maneuver
landing just feet from the first
aircraft outside the wall the last two
helos set down
the soldiers rushing off the aircraft
and taking up security positions
to ensure that none of gadia's men
escaped the assault
shots fired shots fired the operators
inside the courtyard spread out
sweeping forward toward godia the rounds
flying both ways
there was no way out one by one gadia's
men
fell and within minutes the fight was
over cowering unarmed in the small
tent in the middle of the compound were
several young children
and a woman the drone overhead watched
as the operators went from dead man to
dead man
looking for their target minutes later
came the call
jackpot i say again jackpot roger votel
answered a smile coming across his face
this mission had been a long time coming
on target the chaos was subsiding
the gunfire had stopped but the clock
was ticking by now the syrians were
aware
the americans had crossed the border it
was time to go picking up the body of
abu ghadiyah
the assaulters exited the compound
boarded the helos
and within three minutes were back in
iraq
the total time of the mission 17 minutes
but you're right typical mission as you
well know this was uh
at one point in time i think we were
doing between 20 and 25 missions a night
uh in iraq with the the whole force not
not one entity but the entire force um
and and they were they all followed
pretty much the
same sort of method of operation that
you either went in by hilo
or you went in by ground ground assault
and of course the great thing about
iraq from a tactical standpoint from a
commander's standpoint is
you drive to the objective you know if
you're in baghdad or mosul or pick a
place
uh you know you drive 500 feet from the
objective the guys get out you know the
guys put up blocking positions the
assault force comes in breaches the door
away they go
and yeah i would go out with the guys
periodically and we'd hit four or five
targets a night you know just
not there not there up not there you
know and eventually
you get the bad guy um and then of
course the helo ops
we use mainly for getting out into you
know ramadi area and
a little further out but that particular
mission
uh abu ghriyah was probably one of the
one of the
most notorious facilitators and we we
just could never get to him and he was
the guy that was bringing in all the
fighters
foreign fighters from outside iraq and
he would funnel them in through
across the border and uh and into al
qaeda in iraq and we called him at the
time
but he was elusive and finally
when we finally got an opportunity to
get him um
you know i was briefing president bush
uh on the
the video and um and it was interesting
to see you know
it was it was great because the
president was very decisive uh and
i was fortunate in the course of my time
as both the commander and the deputy
i had both president bush and president
obama and i will i will offer
as different as they may have been uh
from a personality standpoint they were
both very decisive when it came to
giving you authority to go get go get
the bad guys and
and this one you know they i remember
president bush going around the table
with uh
uh you know the secretary of defense
secretary of state and they all said
thumbs up and away we went and again
from the
so i gave votel hey you you at your
timeline you go
and he was in iraq at the time and uh
next thing i know
you know 17 minutes i mean 17 minutes
from the time they launched
time across the border get the objective
and back that was i remember when i when
i reported back to the white house
they're like
i'm sorry what it's done it's done
that's right that's done that's building
a good reputation for the troops
holy mackerel uh in the midst of all
this stuff you got going on you get you
get hit with the uh the maersk alabama
and captain phillips
and what's interesting i remember i used
to tell these young
junior officers and platoon commanders
and task unit commanders
if you think these operations are just
gonna show up on your door and like okay
cool then we'll just go execute it
every one of them is a is is like a soap
opera
to try and get it to put together you
have to kind of force these operations
to happen
and and so you've got all that going on
and then here comes this
um the maersk alabama and
it's great you got to read the book
there's all these different assets you
got
people guys moving from different
theaters and guys from the states coming
out you got air assets you got
navy assets chips and logistics for all
those pieces
this is a this is a massive operation
and again i love your tone of voice
when you when you read it in the
audiobook you
keep you keep saying it's a lifeboat
like it's almost comical
and i just went to the udt seal museum
in fort pierce florida where they have
the life they've got it there i haven't
seen it i'll have to take a look yeah i
know it's great and
of course we got some connections there
so you're not allowed to walk inside but
we got to walk inside and check it all
out you can see all the bullet holes are
there and everything
but what i noticed about that um
a couple things number one the authority
and trust that you had with the guys on
the ground
which is the mark of a of the leader
that you want to work for
the one that's not micromanaging the one
that trusts the the guys on the ground
the general patent said the
what do you say the the commander on the
ground is always right and that seemed
to be
your attitude all the time the trust
that you had with the guys on the ground
and what was phenomenal
also as even when that op happened
i remember thinking to myself man if
that happened in 1994
how much different do you think it would
have been a lot different
well you know the interesting thing
about it and you you characterize it
correctly
and and the operators don't even
understand this and nor do they need to
know this
but uh i talked about my time working in
the white house for two years in the
white house
so when i became the jsoc commander uh i
was in a position
to be able to understand how decisions
were made in the white house and also
in the pentagon and i had a great
relationship with
the secretary of defense bob gates and
emerald mike mullen who was the chairman
and of course we'd done a number of
things for the white house that point in
time
but one of the things i used to always
do and i think it infuriated
some folks in the white house in the
pentagon was i would always say
let me pre-position the guys you don't
have to make the decision
you don't have to give me the authority
to do the assault
but what i don't want to do is for you
to give me the authority and then not be
in the window to do it
so let me go ahead and put the guys off
the coast of somalia for
whatever we were going to do and then if
you decide to go go
and finally of course somebody said
you do this every time and you know
that there is this kind of
predisposition that if the guys are
already
out there why not just let them do it i
was like really no i
i didn't know that but that was always a
little bit of the
the game if you will i played in terms
of making sure that i wanted the guys
always to be in a position
uh that if we got the approval to go uh
that that they weren't we weren't now
having to move and then miss the
opportunity because i'd seen it happen
before where
we waited and waited and the decision
was hard and finally people would say
okay we're going to give you permission
to go and you go
i'm sorry man cool it's going to take me
three days to get there it's going to
take me three days to get there and
that's what they didn't understand a lot
it's
three days by the time not just the guys
from the states
but you got to move ships down and ships
don't move very fast you know
um so you know 99 of the time i think
the
the white house and the and the and the
pentagon was was happy that i i
pushed them to be in a position but but
not always but in the case with
the mayor's alabama i mean i get the
call uh
from the joint staff that this uh this
lifeboat's been taken we got a captain
in there and
and uh you may get called to to do this
mission of course i kept thinking
it's a lifeboat um but uh
but very quickly i mean it happened to
be over easter uh
and and it's not that things changed
much over easter as you know
um but i just remember it happened to be
that weekend but you know immediately
hey i know what to do i'm going to get
on the on the video with uh
admiral mullen and i'm going to get on
the video of the white house and we're
going to begin to lay out a plan and i'm
going to
make sure that the guys on the west
coast are ready to move because we got
to get boats i've got to get the fleet
moving
uh interestingly enough for this my one
time that i was proud i was a fleet
commander for a couple of days because
general petraeus chopped the change of
operational control
chopped the fleet assets to me even
though i was actually in afghanistan
and of course what people i think have
trouble understanding is
my situational awareness by the time
this is go my situational awareness in
afghanistan
was almost as good in terms of the
bigger picture of the guys who are on
the ground because
i'm looking at it from the closed
circuit tv that the
that's on board the ship we've got a
drone overhead we've got a lot of these
assets so you can kind of see what's
happening
of course at the end of the day captain
scott moore who was the the commander of
the seal unit there
he's the guy that's running the show on
the ground but scott and i are talking
you know a couple times a day
um but yeah you can't be in a position
as the three star to be telling
okay look i want the snipers in these
positions and i only want the snipers to
do that no no you
you got to rely on the guys that have
been doing this again for years this
point in time
you know they're going to make the best
decision possible that was one of the
things that always
gave me comfort as a commander was
i knew the guys would make as good a
decision
as i would make i needed to put them in
a position
to be successful my job was to get them
to the point where now they could take
action if they needed to and then let
them figure out how to take the best
action
whether that was bin laden raid whether
that was the mayor's alabama whether it
was a thousand other missions
hey you're the commander i'm not going
on the op i'm not going to be the guy
that's in the line of march i'm not
going to be breaching the door
i want to put you in a position to be
successful i want to make sure you got
the right isr
i want to make sure you got the right
you know cap overhead i want to make
sure you got the right artillery i want
to make sure you got the right medevac i
want to make sure we're monitoring a way
that's going to make you successful at
the end of the day
hey young sergeant young petty officer
young captain young lieutenant
whoever you happen to be you take you
take the tackle into this
and and you'll do just fine yeah you'll
screw it up every once in a while
guess what we all do and when that does
we'll take a hard look at why we made
the mistake
and we'll make the corrections and if
somebody screwed it up because they
really did something bad we're going to
hold you accountable
but other than that get out and do the
very best you can
we weren't always successful and we had
some some ops that went south on us
um but i wouldn't change anything about
the way we had set up the organization
to
empower the guys you know at that level
to make the decisions and take the
actions
yeah i in i call that uh the iterative
decision making process that was
one thing that i as i was in charge of
things
and some kind of an operation would come
up or even if it was like a totally
tactical thing of what should we do
right now
i would always make really small
decisions really quickly yeah and
it made people think i was very decisive
because
i would make decisions very quickly they
wouldn't recognize how small decisions i
had made and then i would just adapt
and adjust them as needed as we move
forward but i like the fact that you use
the iterative decision making process
taking small steps to actually put some
to make it easier for the boss to make a
final decision because look we're all
ready just all you need to do is pull
the trigger the weapon's there the site
is on
that we're ready to do this just say go
and we'll go
similar similar one with uh salah ali
salah
naban am i saying that right right sally
nabahan
so you talk about you know again these
there's
relationships and here you had van
hooser on the ground
who's who's like the the epic
seal officer right he was a he was in
vietnam as a marine
and you know lost his leg due to a
parachute accident
and it's just a badass right nothing
stops pete that's right
and and here you are you have so you've
got him below you in the chain of
command where you've got this awesome
trust
and then up the chain of command you've
got mullen and the chairman of the
i mean mullen the admiral mullen the
chairman of the church and chief of
staff and he trusts you
so this is how you you you run this
thing as
through these relationships yeah and it
went fortunately by that time by the
time we went to sally nab on so sally
nabhan
was a guy in somalia but he had been
responsible for
uh two embassy bombings and he was at
one point in time he was like the number
one guy on the fbi's uh
top ten list and then after 911 happens
he
kind of falls a little lower down the
list but but
nobody could find him and again a very
elusive guy hiding in somalia and then
again our
our focus had shifted to iraq and
afghanistan well also we get this lead
on
on nabhan and uh but we didn't know
whether or not
it was him for certain again we had an
oga source
who said hey we think this is him uh and
if it is him he's going to be in a blue
sedan he's going to move up and down the
beach um
so back to that process again it was
okay i'm going gonna
put the guys in a position so we moved a
couple of small boys a couple of
destroyers out there
put some little bird helicopters on them
uh and
set the conditions so that if in fact
we had a bead on nabhon then we were in
a position to react
and uh and to your point about pete van
hooser so again interestingly enough you
talk about the distributed command
so i'm in afghanistan pete is back in on
this in the states
we are both looking at the same feed so
we had a predator overhead a
isr platform and
now i had briefed this because there had
been a lot of concern in the white house
that they didn't want to put helos
anywhere in somalia because of the
blackhawk down incident and no matter
how much i tried to convince them that
really it would be okay
we've we we know how to do this we've
been doing this a lot there was still a
lot of sensitivity to that and i
understood that
um but we had developed this kind of
special bomb at the time
that we could drop from a small airplane
but it was
experimental to say the least um and so
i had been given approval to
okay you can bring the helos in but only
to confirm that you've killed a bad guy
don't want the helos in until the bomb
has been dropped and you've gotten the
bad guy then bring the helos in get the
remains bring it back
yes sir got it well um you know
not always that simple so as the sedan
starts to move
and we believe that to be salinabhan
we've got
i mean it's a long road but there's only
a small window of opportunity where that
that vehicle is not going to be in a
crowded uh
area not a little village or something
because we didn't obviously want to hit
any civilians
so the plane gets overhead we're in the
window
but the plane can't get a bead on the
weather comes in
nothing's looking right we can't get the
targeting right and
now i'm i'm losing my target so
pete van hoose was on the other end
going sir come on you know we're
we need to send the helos in and i'm
like you know
um i was really told kind of not to do
that
but now my target is getting away and
you know you roll the dice and hope that
this is the bad guy that you thought it
was and
so finally i said okay pete you got it
and you know
the helos went in and of course as soon
as the bad guys saw the helos they open
up on us
and hilos open up on them that obviously
doesn't go too well for them these
little bird gun ships
which you're familiar with uh seals get
off
uh the helos uh do a quick chord on i
mean this was right before they were
getting to a little village
pull the bodies out and all four of them
turned out to be bad guys and sally
nabhan was one of them
um and and i remember the next day
or maybe later that day admiral mullen
comes on the video
and uh yeah he's very gracious he goes
well
you know bill congratulations please
pass on my uh congratulations to captain
van hooser and the guys uh
really good job thank you sir and he
goes
no william and i knew i was in trouble
when he called me william
he says now william i recall you
briefing
the president of the united states
that you were going to drop a bomb on
this guy and there were no hilos were
going to come in
yes sir uh well you know every once in a
while
you got to give the commander a little
discretion and the admiral kind of
smiled and
again he said okay william i'll let you
get away with it this time
and uh all all's well it ends well sort
of thing but uh
the president never questioned it and i
think cabral mullin appreciated the
commander's decision
yeah and those the amount of leadership
capital i made sure that one might have
cost you a little bit of leadership
capital but the amount of leadership i
mean will you just talk about the other
op that we
discussed there with uh abu ghadiyah you
know 17 minutes and
and how many as you said thousands of
operations were conducted that
you know look we all we all know some of
them go bad and sideways and that's
awful but
the i mean the batting average of
success was
overwhelmingly it's actually incredible
when you think about it
and and so this this uh
this op tempo and this kind of being
successful on a regular basis and
building that
leadership capital and and
kind of i mean i guess you in my opinion
or the way it looks
the final operation that you you cover
and see stories is
is the first one that i started off with
which like i said is
i guess it's been 10 years
yeah it's been 10 years and and i mean
if that's not the most famous u.s
special operations mission i'm not sure
what is but it's neptune spear
um the raid that killed bin laden and
i mean you you got to get you know the
perspective that you give
um the intelligence gathered
the preparation the secrecy i mean you
got one part where you're talking about
i forget who it is you're talking about
maybe it's your exo or
or your deputy or maybe your ops officer
but
you're not even telling your ops officer
it's complete secrecy
about what's going on the
professionalism in every department
you go through and kind of talk about
the decision-making process and the
discussion to get to these decision
points
and the conversations and the
relationships between you and admiral
mullen and secretary gates and the cia
officials
and then the president who's who who has
to understand and be comfortable with
this
and the i mean this is a tough this is a
freaking hard choice to make
yeah um massive amount of risk
and some other much lower risk in terms
of us
troops and i you know like to to say
oh yeah yeah of all these options we're
going to take the one that puts the
us troops in the in the biggest risk um
just do an incredible job of of spelling
that out in the book
the pilots their skills and then of
course you know you got the seals on the
ground the best guys in the world the
best of the best
um what a what what
what an incredible story well
there were so many people that had to
had to you know make this happen
um and and to your point uh you know
great
trust uh from you know the president on
down
but i look back and i'm always quick to
point out about this and you can
certainly appreciate this
you know we were we were honored to be
the guys that got bin laden and and i
think what
the reason we were honored was because
we were representing
you know the hundreds of thousands of
soldiers sailors airmen and marines
you know and thousands that were killed
in combat and training for combat
uh that had died as a result of 9 11.
um so yeah this was a
i mean this was the brass ring for us
but it was also an
opportunity to represent everybody that
had
had sacrificed so much from iraq and
afghanistan
but on this particular mission you know
back to my earlier
discussion my job i knew my job was to
put the operators in a position where
they were going to be successful
unfortunately early on uh because uh we
referred to it as the bigot list which
is
a world war ii term that says you know
only those people that are authorized to
know the intelligence
so when i was brought into this in late
january
it was me and of course the white house
is looking for a plan
and now fortunately you know
i had been in the teams at 34 years or
so at that point in time and thousands
and thousands of missions
and frankly i did go back to my my
thesis at the post-graduate school and i
figured okay i'll i'll
present a shell of a plan to the present
um
and uh and then we'll take it from there
but the plan was gonna be pretty simple
we're gonna get on a helicopter we're
gonna go from point a to point b we're
gonna get the bad guy put him back on
the helicopter and come home
that's it i had looked at a lot of other
alternatives you know could we parachute
in
uh could we come in by vehicle could we
you know it was there other ways to get
to the target
but every time i looked at that i kind
of came back to my thesis which was
this idea of the point of vulnerability
at what point in time
where would you get tripped up so if we
parachute in you walk into an lz and the
next thing you know there's kids on the
lz or there's
and now you're still 15 16 kilometers
from the target you just ain't gonna
make it
same thing on if we come in by vehicles
what happens if uh you know we get
stopped at a checkpoint and everything
gets busted
uh so i i decided early on that it was
just gonna be uh you know hellos from
point a to point b
um and that's what i bring the president
on and and early on it was just me and i
had a another captain
who was in dc that was kind of covering
for me but to your point i couldn't tell
anybody
i couldn't tell my command sergeant
major i couldn't tell my ex so i i mean
it was
that was it so my executive officer guy
named colonel art sellers who was just
magnificent throughout this i always say
he's kind of the unsung hero
early on i had to tell art because in in
my world i'm a three star
uh admiral and your executive officer is
the guy that i mean he's he's kind of
like an aide to camp
but more so he's the guy to make sure
that every paperwork piece of paperwork
comes in that you've got to take care of
you take care of
anything's happened that's happening the
exo is orchestrating all this
and he becomes your kind of closest
buddy along with your ad to cam
so as i told art early on i said art
something's brewing i don't want you to
ask any questions about it
uh you just need to do what i tell you
and and you know
and we'll be fine he was like former
ranger sir i got it
and uh and art kind of helped me through
all this you know we'd move from point a
to point b
and the staff would call up and go
where's the admiral going
i would say you just get him there you
will worry about where he's going
now the interesting thing was i had been
diagnosed with cancer um
in 2010 and so uh with chronic
lymphocytic leukemia
so the staff was always a little
reluctant to ask me where i was going
and when i kept going back and forth to
washington dc they assumed i was going
to bethesda or walter reed
for for treatment i didn't
again i didn't want to necessarily play
on my cancer diagnosis but i also didn't
want to
disabuse him that idea because it gave
me a little bit of cover for action i
could move
and the staff would just say he's in
washington and people would say what's
he doing
and they would kind of go uh we don't
know but they felt comfortable thinking
it was kind of
part of my cancer treatment finally you
know the president at one point in time
said
well okay you've briefed me on this can
we do it sir
i don't know i mean i've got to bring in
air planners i got to bring in the seals
i got to bring in you know more people
uh before i can really tell you whether
or not we can do this
so the president gave me about three
weeks and that's when i brought the guys
in
to that undisclosed location in uh in
north carolina where you read the uh
excerpt at the beginning and it was
pretty funny because
as as you can appreciate you know these
guys have just come back from a
deployment
i'm often asked you know why did you
pick the seals over the delta force guys
and and they think it was because i was
a seal and was like are you kidding me
uh you think i would risk this mission
based on
you know some parochial nature of who i
thought was uh going to be wearing a
trident or not
so there were two commanders i trusted
implicitly on the army side and the navy
side
unfortunately for the army guys they had
literally
just deployed to afghanistan and the
seal squadron
had just come back so they were all on
leave
so that provided my kind of cover for
action uh because the team
just assumed they were out you know
skiing in tahoe or doing something
so i called the the squadron commander
and i said okay
and then of course pete van hooser the
co
and we move them all down to this
undisclosed location and you know we did
these kind of sensitive training
exercises every once in a while and you
can see when they walked into the room
they were like you sob you called me off
leave with my girlfriend to be
you know kind of showcase something to
the brass and then all of a sudden when
the cia
guy said and we're going after bin laden
it was like
as you read it's like are they serious
you know and i see the guys looking at
each other like
are they serious and then of course
after that it all kind of unfolded but
but again my job was really to not to
push it one of the things i was careful
about doing
because as we would meet with the
president we have a number of options we
had a a kind of a massive bombing option
can we take out this thing we called
ac-1 the abadabad compound one
there's a big compound you've probably
seen pictures every kind of
trapezoid-shaped three-story building a
couple of other
outer buildings but that was going to
take a massive amount of ordinance to
level the place
did did i hear was it something like 30
yeah i think it was more than i was 50
2000 pound bombs in order to level the
place and of course
the the cde the collateral damage
assessment was going to actually
uh hit some of the the outer line houses
and and we knew there were women and
children on the target so i knew from
the get-go the president was
one we didn't know it was bin laden uh
so the president was not gonna
you know kill innocent women and
children uh
at all then we had a second option which
was a more
um surgical bombing option to get the
pacer as you pointed out the guy that
would come out every day around noon
and walk around the compound once again
even with the surgical bombing option
we were probably going to kill a couple
of kids and uh and i think the president
just i know
that was just not what he want to do and
oh by the way we weren't going to be
sure if we did either one of those
bombing options
how would we know whether it was bin
laden the al qaeda could have said
wasn't him unless we had physical
evidence it was
and of course we weren't going to rely
on the pakistanis because we didn't know
whether they had been compromised
um so it didn't take long i think for
the
the group uh the president's small team
to begin to focus in
on the raid and admiral mullen was
always supportive of the raid
uh and and leon panetta who was director
of the cia was always supportive
interestingly enough and i've told this
story before secretary gates
did not support the raid and he didn't
support the raid because he had been in
the white house
during uh desert one when the
helicopters crashed
and at one point in time after one of
the meetings for the president
every time the president at the end of
the meeting would kind of go around the
room okay where are we now and uh
and they would say well i'm for it i'm
against it and he would turn to
secretary gates and say
mr president i don't support the raid
and so after the
briefing was over i came up the
secretary i said sir
i work for you if you don't support the
reading you don't want me to uh to do
this
just say the word i mean you know that's
your call and he said something i
thought was just
you know again fabulous leadership he
said bill said i don't agree with the
raid
but we've got to give the president
every option
available and if the raid is an option
then i want him to i want you to do the
best you can to plan for it prepare for
it
and give him that option at the end of
the day the president will make the
decision
but just because i don't support it
doesn't mean we're not going to put that
option in front of the president and
again i thought that was very classy of
him and the kind of leader that you
would hope to have in that chain of
command
um but i remember the
second last meeting we had the president
again because we were
struggling with determining whether it
was bin laden he turned to
mike lighter who was the director of the
national counter-terrorism center
which had been stood up after 9 11. and
he asked
lyden to kind of red team cia's
intelligence to kind of check their
homework
so uh the next meeting we were at which
was a
couple weeks later meeting starts end of
april meeting starts off and the
president turns to the lighter and he
says well mike you know what did you
find
i could tell lighter was a little
uncomfortable he goes uh well mr
president we
we've reviewed ci's intelligence and we
think the chance that it's bin laden is
anywhere between
60 and 40 and when you said 40
i'm thinking oh well i mean this
mission's over who in the hell is going
to authorize a bunch of seals to fly 162
miles
into pakistan to a compound that is
about three miles from their west point
three miles from a major infantry
battalion you know a mile from a police
station
and oh by the way the pakistanis have
nuclear weapons i mean who would
authorize that on a 40
chance that it's been locked so
i told the president i said sir you know
i've got to head to afghanistan i'm
going to command it from there
if you decide to go uh great i'll have
the boys ready to go if you decide not
to go
not a problem i got bad guys in
afghanistan we'll just kind of get back
to work
so that was on a wednesday i fly out to
afghanistan and
got there sometime on friday and i get a
call from leon panetta the director cia
and he says
presidents made the decision to go and i
thought wow
that is a gutsy decision uh i mean in
light of the fact that we just didn't
know it was bin laden
uh and but this is back to the kind of
discussion we've been having
all throughout this uh the podcast is
the president had seen
i think over the time that you know we'd
been conducting
missions that we were mostly successful
he he had faith and confidence in us
um in a way that uh you know every
commander would hope
that their bosses had had confidence in
them and we hadn't got them all right
i mean again when i was jsoc commander
we had a couple of uh notable
uh disasters frankly and uh but even at
that
the president recognized that you know
the failures we had
um were understandable in light of some
of the circumstances around it and
things don't always go perfect but he
had confidence that we could do this and
uh so the next day saturday the
president calls me
and he says he called to really tell the
guys you know good luck
and it was interesting because you know
man-to-man you can tell
you know even though he's the president
united states he had this
empathy you could tell he understood
these guys are about to get on this
helicopter
and fly into pakistan didn't know
whether they would come back because of
course we didn't know whether or not
was the compound rigged because as you
saw in iraq quite a few times you know
these guys would rig the entire
compounds
uh was bin laden going to be wearing a
suicide vest
you know what what were they going to be
facing and so as president united states
he understood those risks and and i
could tell
you when he asked me to pass on you know
his best to the guys i mean he seriously
meant that he understood
the risks they were taking and you know
as a commander that means a lot to you
and i did take the opportunity to pass
that on
but then i remember he said uh well bill
what do you think i said
well mr president i mean if he's there
we'll get him
if not we'll come home the problem with
the if not
will come home scenario which i had
briefed the president on i said look if
the seals get on target
and somebody comes out with a gun it is
not going to go too well for them
and as they begin to sweep through the
target which they will and more people
come out with guns and you know iraq and
afghanistan and pakistan people have
guns it's not going to go well and as
they go from the first floor to the
second floor to the third floor looking
for bin laden
and if they get to the third floor and
the guy we thought was bin laden
turns out to be nothing but a tall
pakistani this is going to be a disaster
of epic proportions i didn't tell the
president that
but he understood that because we had
talked about the fact that
i told him early on i told everybody
there if the seals get on target
somebody's going to die you just need to
understand that right now nobody is
going to walk away from this
unscathed um so understand those risks
to the president and the other team so i
understood that
and uh and again back to the fact that
uh he had
faith and confidence in us um we kept it
secret we kept it simple
and then of course the day of the
operations the guys executed it
exactly as you would hope they would
you got a story in i think it's in the
hero code
uh no actually it's in c stores it's the
story about where
where you uh get in trouble you get kind
of caught by your dad
well not caught by your dad but you get
caught you you you tried to infiltrate
a military what was it a more ammo story
an ammo storage thing you
you know you think you're james bond or
whoever and
you infiltrate you got a cap gun on your
on your you know a six-shooter cap gun
with you
and and you you infiltrate a freaking
military compound with your buddy
and then they chase you out of there
they're coming they've got dogs looking
for units
it's like a serious operation and
at some point you drop your pistol you
get back
and uh you know you get you get away
with it get away with it
your dad says hey your dad you know next
day or whatever it is
you know dad says hey there was someone
tried to infiltrate you know anything
about that
and you lied to him yep
and it seems like you could tell by the
look on his face that he knew that you
lied to him
you suspected you went to bed that night
you pulled down your covers uh to get in
bed and there's your there's your gun
so he knew um
you talk a lot about integrity and you
know telling the truth and
and i think you know when you're when
you're talking about um discussing these
things up the chain of command and it's
you know i i would you got to tell the
truth about what's happening
but you develop that kind of trust with
your whole chain of command
from the secretary of defense to the
president so that when you
say something they actually believe what
you're saying and that might
that might seem really uh like like a
like a insignificant
thing but if you think about what's
riding on this
operation for america
for the world if they don't have that
like
legitimate pure trust in what you're
telling them
i i can't imagine i can't imagine making
the decision giving the go-ahead to
someone that i don't
deeply and truly trust
a hundred percent yeah you know you
asked
earlier on about about my dad and i
think you know we're we're all kind of
products of our experience and i was
i was fortunate to be raised by two
great parents
but uh my mom stressed it a lot um
about you know the importance of of
truth and honesty and she expected me to
grow up to be a certain type of man a
man that would
open doors for for ladies that would you
know take care of women and children
i mean she had this this vision of me
i was going to be a stand-up guy and
honest and true
and all those sorts of things and you
you always want to
uh make your parents proud and this
particular day and you're right i was 11
years old and we
we tried to get into this ammo storage
point near lachlan air force base we got
busted and i dropped the cap gun
and when i and it was a day or so later
my dad was the head of operations so he
was the number three guy at lachlan air
force base
so the security guys had reported to him
that and they knew some kids
they didn't know who it was but they
knew some kids that tried to break in um
and and when my dad confronted me as i
said in the book it's the first
and last time i ever lied to my father
um
and uh and he never until he died in
he never raised the issue again and the
reason i thought that was interesting
parodying this because
i carried that burden until until he
died in 2007.
but there was another one i mentioned my
time in the pentagon
and again we all to your point jacob we
all are raised
with this idea that it is of course
you're going to be honest
you know of course you're not going to
lie to people and you find
you know that as you go through life
sometimes that's harder to do than it is
to say
but when i was in the pentagon i worked
for a guy named captain ted grabowski
and grabowski vietnam are sealed um
was a little quirky uh for a seal didn't
look like a seal he was kind of short in
stature the spectacle had
had more glasses he'd been in a glider
accident and he had a little bit of a
of a limp and so did not look like
you're your typical seal
but i found him to be brilliant
hard-working
incredibly insightful and he knew the
pentagon but it was on like day one or
the first week i was there at one point
in time
we're we're talking about our budget uh
with a three-star admiral
and uh and i thought grabowski we had
this opportunity
we were going to get a whole bunch of
money for our ammunition and our and our
seal delivery vehicles and the the
admiral questioned grabowski and he said
do you really need all of this money i
mean can't you take a little slice off
the the ammunition do you really need
that many sdvs
and i thought grabowski's going to stand
he's going to say absolutely i need that
and much to my surprise he goes you know
what admiral you're right
uh we can cut our our uh ammunition
allowance by this we can reduce the
number of sdvs from six to three and
i thought what the hell just happened
why'd he do that
and afterwards i'm talking to him and he
says look billy says
i've got one rule when you're here in
the pentagon he says
never lie or misrepresent
the truth because if you lie or
misrepresent the truth
somebody will find out and they will no
longer trust you
and if they don't trust you you are of
no value to me
and it was a little bit of this kind of
philosophical linkage between
it wasn't just about the moral
application of being
honest there was a practical application
as well
which is if you are honest if you are
trustworthy people will trust you with
their money they will trust you with
their
relationships they will trust you with
their lives they will trust you with the
big missions
and it isn't just about saying well you
know
i'm just not going to lie sometimes
people misrepresent the truth
that they embellish things in a way that
is you know
to their benefit or in a way that will
get them the mission
i mean i knew on the bin laden raid
there was no way i was going to mislead
the president of the united states
and i hope in my time in the military i
didn't mislead
anybody at least not not
willingly and not there or not
intentionally so
it is it's it is important not just
because we know it's important to be
honest but because if you're not honest
and you're not trustworthy you can't
build those relationships if you can't
build the relationships you can't get
the job done
how many times had you guys or you seen
various units get spun up to go get bin
laden
yeah a lot of times um and that was yeah
part of it when i first
was approached by admiral mullen in
afghanistan he said hey cia's got a lead
on bin laden
i mean i was respectful to admiral
mullen of course but i'm thinking i've
seen this picture before
i mean we you know we'd had him in the
hindu kush we'd had him in tora bora
again
uh you know we'd had him in pakistan a
number of times i mean
uh you know he was like trying to find
waldo i mean it seemed like bin laden
was everywhere i remember one point in
time
we had a lead on him up in the hindu
kush it was something like
you know 12 14 000 feet or something
like that
up in the middle of nowhere and somebody
said he's hiding in a cave up there
so because the altitude was so high i
could only put two guys on the 47.
i put an air force sts guy and and one
other guy and so
the helicopter can barely make it up to
altitude and of course something this is
just a wild goose chase
but they came back and said the the
young i think he was a captain or a
major comes to brief me and he says
i'll say obviously ben lasse says but
there were footsteps up there in the
snow
and i'm like really he said out in the
middle of nowhere we we followed these
footsteps into this kind of little cave
area i'm thinking
really yeah of course it was not bin
laden it was
something but it was so yeah we had a
lot of leads like that we had some leads
in pakistan that uh
i mean i remember seeing uh be a little
careful about this but i remember seeing
intel
uh and i looked at and said well that's
him there's there is no question in my
mind
but it wasn't him because in fact he was
in that compound in a badabad for
probably five years
uh and and never left that compound um
so yeah yeah there were a lot of leads
out there but this was the only one that
panned out
what was the timeline from the first
time you talked to admiral mullins that
he said he had a lead
and execute yeah so he he approached me
in december
of uh of 2010. i didn't i wasn't asked
to come back to uh
the states until january february of
2011.
so uh in in the february time frame i
spent a lot of time with cia kind of
looking at the intel
uh and then i think i had my first
meeting with the president sometime in
march and then we had a bunch of
meetings between march and the end of
april
and so uh april 30th or somewhere around
there is when i left for afghanistan
maybe april 29th and then got to
afghanistan and then we
you know we launched two days later and
how what was the timeline for the boys
from that meeting from that meeting when
they signed the non-disclosures
yeah so that was probably uh five weeks
four or five weeks so that was so we
spent three weeks
uh you know briefing up doing all the
rehearsals
um and then at the end of that three
weeks when i went back and met with the
president said we can do this
uh yeah i think that was towards the end
of april so
i had general tony thomas who was my
number two guy there at jsoc
uh i had to stay in in washington and i
said okay tony let's let's get the
guys from the states let's get it moved
out there now so tony along with pete
van hooser and of course we had
cia and national security agency and
national spatial agency and
and a whole kind of interagency group
that went with us uh but tony's got us
set up in this little talk
tackle operation center there in the in
jbad and zlalalabad and uh
so when i came out uh i mean it was uh
the guys were set everything was ready
to go i ended up rolling it
uh about we're gonna we were gonna
launch on saturday but there was some
from some fog in the uh
in the area and the temperatures were a
little high at the time uh so i rolled
it 24 hours and then
and then we pressed forward on sunday
um like i said you got to get the book
um for the details
and all leading up to this but there's
one little part i wanted to cover
um the missions be actually being
executed so you're in this in the in the
operation center
and here we go inside the jock i was
getting updates from van hoosier and
thompson
the seals were clearing we're still
clearing the three-story house and the
helos were holding
their position outside a badabad
i looked up at the clock 15 minutes had
passed since the assault began
sir the squadron commander is on the
radio van hoosier alerted me
the voice was unmistakable deep calm
in control this is romeo 6
6. he paused and you could hear a small
shutter in his voice
for god and country geronimo
geronimo geronimo
the hunt for the most wanted man in the
world was over we
had gotten bin laden the jock erupted in
cheers
immediately followed by van hoosier's
booming voice
shut the [ __ ] up he yelled we still have
to get these guys home
the jock immediately quieted down van
hoosier was right
we still had a long way to go i had no
sense of relief
no internal exhilaration no feeling of
victory
the mission was not over
and when i read that i just thought to
myself
i mean what a freaking professional uh
van hoosier
and you could see i mean here it is you
know the
the ultimate mission capturing the
ultimate bad guy or killing the ultimate
bad guy
and and everyone's all excited and van
hooser's just on point
just just no deviation it always was
freaking outstanding and it's
interesting too because
you call back and say yep we got we got
geronimo we got it done
and then you realize wait is he dead or
alive
well i had to report back to panetta
yeah
uh i think he'd heard the geronimo and i
i just said you know dry and then i
thought
oh [ __ ] because you know much everybody
thinks that this was a kill-only mission
it was not
we had a plan to capture him if if in
fact he gave up and there was he was
clearly not a threat
and then i realized i don't know whether
he's dead or alive so i had to call back
down to the
squadron commander and say geronimo ekia
question mark
ekia so there was a few second pause and
i think the
guys in the white house and they were
like i thought he already reported
geronimo as i said no
he's dead so let's make sure we
understand that
um i mean like i said you go into
what happened after after that it's just
a incredible
story i mean obviously it's incredible
story
get the book to check that stuff out uh
before before i close out the book see
stories there's one
one one other little section i wanted to
cover
it's from a it's from a chapter called
the greatest
the next greatest generation and this
this takes this section takes place in
2007 we mentioned that you were in
europe for a time
you were in charge of all special
operations forces in europe and africa
but that means you're
actually over in germany most of the
time and
in this part you're visiting wounded
soldiers on their way home from iraq and
afghanistan so on the way home from
iraq and afghanistan oftentimes the the
soldiers the wounded would be would stop
in germany
and at launch stool and you would go
there to visit these
wounded guys and um you talk about one
of these
one of these cases here so you're going
in to visit
going to the book the doctor nodded and
i pushed
the door open and entered lying on the
bed completely naked was a young soldier
not more than 25 years old
his body was swollen from the impact of
the blast burns covered the upper half
of his torso
and below his waist he had lost half of
one leg and much of the other
his face was so badly damaged that his
eyes were almost sealed shut
and his lips burned clean off
life-saving tubes extended from just
about every orifice
in his body and monitors around the room
beeped continuously
sir he can't talk but he can hear you
and he likes to engage people the doctor
said
i slowly walked up beside the bed
hey partner my name's admiral mcraven
i could see him acknowledge my presence
you look like [ __ ] he managed to smile
and reached out his hand
toward the nightstand the doctor grabbed
a clipboard and handed it to the soldier
he likes to write out his responses the
doctor said
pulling the attached pen from its holder
he scribbled on the notepad
you should see the other guy
i laughed and he chuckled with me looks
like they're taking good care of you
is there anything you need once again he
grabbed the clipboard
and wrote a beer
the doctor looked at me and reluctantly
shook his head well i'll tell you what
when you get back to the states get well
and the beer's on me he just nodded
i was struggling with what to say i had
been in these situations hundreds of
times before
and all you could do is make small talk
normally i knew the soldier or his unit
and i had something more significant to
offer i walked around to the doctor's
side of the bed
is he a marine or a soldier i whispered
to the doctor
sir i don't know i'm just the attending
physician i can find out for you though
no not necessarily not necessary walking
back around to my side of the bed i
leaned over to the young man and asked
are you a marine or a soldier he seemed
agitated by the question he pointed to a
tattoo
that was etched on his thigh he must
have assumed that the tattoo is fully
visible
but the blast had burned the leg so
badly that only a smudged
outline appeared i looked closely and
could see
the image of a big red one the first
infantry division
you're a soldier i commented he grabbed
the clipboard
infantry he wrote infantry
the toughest occupation in the army i
thought the soldiers
are always marching always carrying a
rucksack always in the line of fire
you have to be strong and fit to last in
any infantry unit
particularly during war as i glanced at
the young man's battered body
i wondered if he fully understood the
degree of his injuries
he noticed me assessing his physical
condition and suddenly
a look of defiance came across his
swollen face he rolled in my direction
and then wrote slowly in capital letters
i will be infantry again
so that's um you know like you said it's
something that you witnessed hundreds of
times and
and and one thing that you write in the
books and i've heard you talk about it
as well
is with all these
wounded soldiers that you've you know
soldiers sailors airmen and marines that
you've gone and talked to
every single one of them every single
one of them
has just wanted to get back their unit
and get back in the fight
yeah and you've been there you know that
and it is remarkable to me
and i think of the to your point you
know hundreds of these guys that i've
met never once
did i hear anybody complain i mean guys
that lost arms and legs and blast
victims
and they didn't complain
it's just amazing to me i i don't know
if i tell the story in that book but
i've told the story before
when i was socom commander i went up to
to walter reed and i used to do it
periodically same thing when the guys
would get back
and
i know i had um before you jump into
that i had
one of my guys ryan jobe who uh
was shot in the face he was blinded
um and i'm talking to him you know he's
back
he's at i think he's at bethesda and i'm
talking to him from ramadi
and you know he's begging me to come
back
and he says you know sir i'll get my pig
you know he's a pig gun or he's a 60
gunner
he goes sir give me my pig don't worry i
might not be able to see him
but i can smell him i'll get him and
and you know there's just the the
attitude and same thing with the first
guy that i had that
got badly wounded a guy named cowie
cowie and
cowie was you know we know if he's going
to keep his leg but he was shot up bad
he's on
morphine or whatever he's on and we
we've been in ramadi for a very short
period of time at this point
and i get to the to the to the uh
charlie med the field medical area and i
roll in there
and he's you know he he holds out his
hand and
and i grab his hand and he like pulls me
in close
and he just whispers he's you know sir
let me stay
i'll sweep up just please let me stay
don't send me home and and you know
here's a guy
that's a freaking incredible athlete
incredible guy
and we don't know if he's going to keep
his leg and the only thing he cares
about
is you know can i stay
right yeah and this again
it seemed like and it was of course just
the soft guys you saw it again and again
with all the guys that we encountered
but this one particular
visit i had up to walter reed i'd come
up see some of our kind of soft guys
rangers
and and others who've been wounded and
couple again and of course walter reed
was where we sent the
frankly the most seriously injured
certainly the the blast victims and the
uh
and the amputees the barn victims
generally went to down fort sam
but i'm up there visiting a couple of
guys and talking to them them and their
wives and everything and you know
you know how to talk to these guys
they're guys that that
are our rangers or delta operators or
seals and
and and that particular day i there were
three or four of them there and then
afterwards a sergeant major who's
escorting me around says hey so there's
somebody else i'd like you to meet
he's not a soft guy he's with the 25th
infantry division
and he was in iraq in a vehicle vehicle
got hit by an explosively formed
projectile
he is a quadruple amputee
and i said hey absolutely i'd love to go
meet him so i go up to the
to the second floor of the rehab center
there i see the young man
standing off to the side and he's kind
of leaning up against the rail and of
course
he's only about yay big because he's got
no legs and so i come over
to talk to him and i kneel down so i can
kind of get eye to eye with him and
i know what to say i mean what do you
tell a young kid who's
lost both his legs all of one arm and
most of the other arm
and so as i'm i'm trying to make some
small talk i mean he obviously
saw some in my eyes you know the pity of
remorse or something
and he turns me he says sir i'm 24 years
old
i'm going to be just fine i never forgot
that
i'm 24 years old and i'm gonna be just
fine and all he wanted to do was
this unit was still in iraq and he said
can you
get me back to hawaii so i can be there
when the 25th infantry division comes
back
so i think we can manage that and we did
and he was able to get there and meet
his unit when they came back
well outstanding that's um and that's
you know
again a lot of the book is obviously
focuses around special operations and
and as you point out as we both know the
the
the sacrifices absolutely made by the
entire
the entirety of the the us military
um is just it's it's incredible it's
incredible and the bravery the bravery
doesn't
the bravery doesn't stay in one unit
it's in all these units
and um incredible to see
um
you end up as the bullfrog in the seal
teams
which is which means that you at
however many maybe you had it for a year
or two i'm not sure but that means you
had more
time in the seal teams than anybody else
in the seal teams at that time on active
duty right
how long did you how long are you the
bullfrog for it so bullfog for for three
years
uh so i i share so i i was made the
bullfrog at
34 years into the teams and i shared it
with a guy named brian siebenhaller who
was probably a captain at the time
but brian and i had gone through
training together so uh
and brian was young enlisted trooper
when we went through training then of
course he went to
i think he made senior chief then with
ocs and and has a long career as an
officer
absolutely fabulous officer great friend
i hope to run into him while i'm here
uh so brian and i because we had been in
the same class we we shared the
the bullfrog for a couple years then
brian retired and i i i think i ended up
flying solo for
about the last year of my time as the
socom commander but
yeah for the last three years um yeah i
mean part of this is just longevity you
know
you just you keep swinging away and uh
yeah 37 years
but it goes by fast you know i was i had
a chance to talk to one of the
seal classes yesterday and i said
i said let me let me tell you a little
story i said you know when i retired in
2014 and i i had a chance to be the
chancellor of the university of texas
system so
230 000 kids 100 000 employees great
great
opportunity but i would meet these uh
you know these these very uh successful
captains of industry um that were
billionaires you know and everywhere you
went and they were they were great they
were actually very very good people i
really
enjoyed uh the folks that i had a chance
to meet
but they were all envious of me and all
the money in the world
could not get them the opportunity to
lock out of a submarine or fast rope out
of a helo
or you know jump out of a plane from 30
000 feet at night on o2
and as successful as they had been
they didn't have the experiences they
didn't have 37 years
of being in the locker room being with
the guys
getting harassed every day in a
good-natured manner and and
and being with guys that were
sacrificing their families that were
sacrificed they didn't have that
experience
so i told these uh young students going
through buds i said guys let me tell you
something
you still got there in second phase so
they still got a long ways to go i said
you know you're going to have those days
still left in training where you're
going to want to quit
don't do it don't do it because once you
pin that trident on
your life changes forever and and you'll
have hard days in the teams
you're absolutely going to have hard
days and i said i was fired i had
missions that didn't go well
but when you look back over your time in
the teams whether you spent four years
or 40 years you'll never regret a moment
of it because you're going to have
friends and stories and adventures that
your you know your friends from high
school and college will never have had
uh and when you're old and gray like i
am and you're sitting in your rocking
chair and you'll be able to look back on
that and say
you know what that was a pretty good run
i wouldn't trade it for anything
the um person that you shared the
the bull frog with yup yeah he was my he
was my platoon commander there you go
you mentioned you know earlier today we
were talking and you you mentioned
something else about
the trident and and who
who owns that trident yeah yeah same
thing talking to the
the guys going through training i said
look you know if you get your trident
you need to understand
it's not your trident it's not joe's
trident it's not john's trident
it's it's all of our tridents you
represent everybody that
ever wore a triton and everybody that's
ever going to wear a trident
so you have a responsibility as a member
of this community
to wear that trident with honor with
dignity
every single day and i i also told him
another story
about you you mentioned the parachute
accident
and and after my parachute accident
about a year
year and a half afterwards i'm still in
the white house and i go down to naval
special warfare group two
and the commodore was having a
commander's conference so all the
officers had kind of assembled there
and i'm still i'm barely walking well by
now but you know we're gonna do what
team guys do we're gonna have pt in the
morning we're gonna do a 10 mile run
so we kind of break out the pt circle
and of course it's push-ups sit-ups
all that sort of stuff and i'm i'm
struggling to get through the basics
because i've got my abs are not back the
pelvis is still hurting
but i faked my way through the pt now
we're gonna go for the run
and uh i think we went out to whatever
the salt point state park not at some
point uh whatever the state park state
park yeah yeah
but we're gonna do two five mile loops
or something like that
so we start off on the run and i hang
for all about 100 yards and then
everybody just leaves me
so but hey i'm gonna i'm gonna do what i
can so i'm i'm kind of
walking jogging trying to finish the run
well a few minutes later the guy that's
the lead runner you know he comes
around on the first loop of the two mile
run and he sees me and of course at this
time i'm a navy captain i've been in for
20 some odd years
and he kind of pulls up beside me and he
says uh
sir what are you doing i said what do
you mean he goes
what are you what are you doing i mean
you're coming off a bad parachute
accident
he said you got nothing left to prove
and i remember i thought about that for
a long time and he was absolutely wrong
and i told these young guys i said every
single
day that you wake up and you wear that
trident
you've got something to prove and if the
time comes
that you think you're too senior or too
entitled
or that you've done it long enough that
you don't have anything left to prove
you're the wrong guy for the job and you
need to leave because
i don't care whether you're an ensign or
a seaman or a four-star admiral
every single day
you wake up you got something to prove
um and
if you don't take that attitude then
you're probably not the right person for
the job
something i wanted to ask you about
because you you mentioned it real quick
um
you know you were talking about hey we
had a lot of success and we sat here and
you know you and i nodded her head
talking about how great you know we had
been and the the special operations
community and
i talked about i talked about this
incredible batting average right and all
that
and and then you know you were saying um
things always didn't go well
when things went bad you know and i i
you know i've i've had things go
horribly horribly wrong
and um you know it's it's one of those
things that
really stings
what do you have any um advice or any
stories where you remember
where something went wrong and you had
to
own it yeah unfortunately
probably way too many stories um but
the one consistent part of when things
go wrong
is you got to own it i mean you have to
you're the person responsible
and what you don't want to do is you
don't want to say well look i know i'm
in charge but but it was really the
you know the young captain of the major
or the seal lieutenant commander i mean
it's real no no i'm sorry you're the guy
in charge
you're responsible now that doesn't mean
you got to get fired every time but that
means that you have got to take
ownership of the problem you've got to
figure out how to
make sure that problem doesn't happen
again you have to hold the people
accountable
if the mistakes they made were
were mistakes of laziness or of not
being moral legal and ethical
then you have to hold them accountable
and even when
they did everything right and they screw
up you still have to hold them
accountable doesn't mean you have to
fire them but you have to hold them
accountable so that everybody
understands look we got a standard
this is the standard we have to maintain
and and if you don't live up to the
standard
you are going to be held accountable
because lives are at risk
but the first person you have to hold
accountable is yourself
um and so you know most the time
certainly over in combat
when things would go wrong uh i had to
go see the four star
and say this is on me because you know
and again this gets back to the navy
mentality as you all know i mean
in the navy because the navy has always
had this kind of
shipboard mentality and for your
listeners you know when you are the
commanding officer of a ship
you are responsible for everything that
happens on that ship and when you pull
away from the pier
the commanding officer is king i mean he
is he or she now
is responsible for everything that
happens and the navy
understands that look if you were the
commanding officer and your ship runs
the ground
and you were asleep in your stateroom
and the young junior officer who was on
the helm
or was the the officer of the deck
failed to wake you up even though you
had told them to wake you up
i'm sorry that's still on you because
you created an atmosphere
of fear or something where that junior
officer didn't feel
like he had the latitude to wake you up
in the middle of a crisis
so you see it happen a lot and people
say well why would you hold the
commanding officer responsible
when he left orders for that junior
officer to wake him up before
things got bad and the point of the navy
is
of this idea this tradition in the navy
that the commanding officer is
responsible is because
then you didn't train them well then you
didn't create the the
culture for them to do the right thing
something was wrong
when you were the commanding officer so
frankly throughout
my time in the navy and certainly in the
special operations community at the end
of the day
it's about me now you know fortunately
you know your bosses know that hey when
things go south
uh your job is also to correct the
problem
sometimes the problem is with you i mean
i think back on a
hostage rescue that we had and i'm
always careful about telling the story
but we had a hostage rescue that did not
go well and the hostage ended up getting
killed
and uh and unfortunately the guys didn't
tell me the truth about the situation
but i also looked back on this and
realized that
some of this was on me because at the
time as i mentioned i was kind of
bouncing back and forth between iraq and
afghanistan and this mission had come up
and normally in a hostage rescue
situation i mean we
treat it you know like it is a no
kidding and national mission and we are
going to do everything possible
but because we were running so many
missions sometimes in afghanistan
um it's not that the guys didn't take it
seriously but we probably didn't follow
all the steps that we normally would
have taken if this had been a national
mission
and i think some of that played into why
we didn't do the detailed planning that
would have helped
again would it have changed the outcome
i don't know
but i remember thinking afterwards uh
yet the guys on the ground
kind of failed to do what they probably
should have done and we held them
accountable
uh i personally held them accountable
but i also kind of had to
look myself in the mirror and say hey
you know uh
at the end of the day maybe you should
have provided better oversight
and asked harder questions rather than
deferring to somebody else to do it
so but here's one other thing i would
offer to you
you know you're going to make mistakes
and the one thing i tell folks
that are learning to be leaders is
particularly in combat
you're going to make mistakes but you've
got to be ready to make the next
tough decision because if you are afraid
to make the next tough decision
when the last mission went bad then
you're not the leader we need you to be
particularly in combat again every once
in a while i would have a mission that
would go south
and i knew we could have done things
better and i realized
now the next mission comes along and you
say [ __ ] i need to
i don't know should i do this should i
not do this and if you start to doubt
yourself
if you start to question too much if
you're afraid to make the the tough
decisions
then you're putting guys lives at
greater risk
so yeah again you got to learn from
those mistakes
you got to do the best you can but as
the leader
you got to be prepared to make the next
tough decision and if you're not
for fear of failing again it's time to
move on
and and i always found that when things
went south
invariably another opportunity would
particularly in combat another
opportunity is not far around the corner
okay now uh now let's let's
uh put our a-game on and you know you
talked about when i got fired
same thing when a mission goes south and
now you know have another opportunity
and you double down on everything you
want to make sure you are
uh you're doing everything you can to be
successful and get beyond that bad
mission
um and that's how people progress
but yeah yeah unfortunately um yeah too
many times uh
that uh the things didn't go well
but i'd like to think that the ledger
shows we had more successes
than we had failures but i do remember
one time on a particular target
in a country not iraq and afghanistan
that i needed permission to take a
strike the intelligence
said hey i had a matter of minutes
before the
the bad guy moved off target so
without staying too many names i i get
to the four star and i said
i need permission from the president to
take this strike in two minutes
i get permission back from president
obama to take the strike so i take the
strike
and it's not the right guy now the good
news is it was a bad guy
the bad news is it was not the guy i
thought it was
and and so now the white house comes
back and and says
um hey um
you know the president made this
decision and and
it you it didn't pan out the way you'd
hoped i got it it was a bad guy but
you know we were you were getting the
president's permission because
you said it was this guy so i had so i
said yeah mia culpa
and let me explain to you how i came to
that decision and a long story between
you know certain as you know handheld
radios don't have the same fidelity et
cetera et cetera
but it forced me to go back and say okay
i just put the chain of command
in a difficult position they trusted me
and i let them down
i let them down because maybe i rushed
it too much
trying to get a win and
and you have to go back and reassess but
the last thing you want to do
is put your boss in a situation where
they trusted you and and you you let
them down
uh i mean i i had one mission that went
south and i remember my boss
you know you don't mind getting wire
brushed you know when you're
so you know wire brush me you know when
somebody calls you up and just
rips you apart uh you know i got used to
that
uh i mean combat that happens um but i
remember one point in time i had a
mission kind of go south and the
and the four star when i had him on the
phone i was explaining things he goes
bill i am really disappointed in you and
your men
and man yeah that uh that's a knife in
the heart sort of thing
um and he had a right to be but we
cleaned it up
got back to business and then i remember
a couple years later
uh he and i were having lunch and he
said uh
do you remember that incident oh yes sir
i
do remember that incident he goes you
covered really you recovered very well
and uh
and you did a great job and then you
know again that's that's what you want
your bosses to say
you know that they appreciate the work
you do
well at uh the bullfrog for three years
and and in what was it uh
you actually did the commencement speech
at the university of texas before you
retired
i did yeah um i was about to say you're
a you're a shining example
of the of the fact that the zero defect
uh attitude is wrong right you know you
have that that zero defect attitude of
hey if if someone fails one time get rid
of them or if someone makes a mistake or
if they're not perfect
get rid of them um with all due respect
sir
you are an outstanding example of you
know someone that someone that's
you know but i don't want to say you had
plenty of defects along the way
but a few mistakes but there certainly
are i mean uh just so people understand
you know when you get fired from a
position
and as a naval officer that can be that
that often times the end of your career
so you can hang on for a couple more
years but
yeah that could be the end of your
career yeah um i mean i was blessed with
again great people
who gave me a second chance and uh
you know as i said earlier i think you
know every once while we all need second
chances
um and again i was fortunate in my
career number times i remember
we had one one particular mission uh
where i went across the border into
pakistan it was my first mission
actually as a jsoc commander
and without going into too much detail
bad guys
we'd been looking at this target for a
long time
um and my first mission as the commander
and i have i mean i've rolled the dice
i've i've always been a bit of a risk
taker so we wanted to go get this target
so we go in
and guys kind of get compromised just as
they're coming
onto the target gun battle ensues
bad guys get killed uh but we wanted to
capture them because we knew they had
intel
and anyway the mission does not go well
so i come back and
um so now i've got a report back to my
boss who was general marty dempsey who
was the centcom commander at the time
so i called him up and i said hey sir
you know here's
here's what happened and obviously i'm
i'm not too
happy about it kind of went through it
and he says okay bill okay fine
so hang up hang up the phone a few
minutes later phone rings
there's general dempsey on the phone he
says hey bill you sounded a little down
so yes sir so you know the mission
didn't go as planned he goes it's okay
man i mean missions are not always going
to go as planned and
you know you made all the right
decisions but as we all know the enemy
gets a vote sometimes
he said don't don't let this shake you
you know you just keep doing what you're
doing and i tell you that
my first mission as a jsoc commander and
when the centcom commander has your back
like general dempsey did and i mean
that's when you i said you need people
up
up the chain of command that believe in
you even when things don't go well
and i always hope that when i was in
command and and officers below me
struggled sometimes uh i would take the
officers analyst that i take the time to
go down and say
it's okay you know things don't always
go well
get back up on the horse and let's keep
moving i mean if you've got confidence
in these guys
now again there's some guys you just got
to say you know what you weren't meant
to be in this position and i had
you know you got i had to fire a few
people too and some of them you know as
as good as they might have been in
training when it came time for combat
it just it wasn't they weren't right for
it and then you had to move them on as
graciously as you could if they they
weren't the right guy for the job
but again i was blessed throughout my
career to have people that had
confidence in me and
and continued to give me second chances
and and and put me in a position to be
successful
early on in my last deployment to ramadi
i had a had a blue on blue had a
fracture side take place
and you know it's a freaking complete
and utter nightmare
and on a friendly iraqi soldier got
killed one of my guys got wounded
several other
friendly iraqis got wounded um
and the army the army
working in ramadi was kind of like hey
you know like
it happens almost but that's not a very
special operations
attitude um you know
at all uh van hoosier happened to be
coming through country
at the time and he happened to stop by
shark base at the time which was my
little base and and
you know he was a marine in vietnam and
he said hey jocko i was in way city and
he goes and i wasn't he goes i didn't
fight in way city but i was there
afterwards
and it's urban combat and this [ __ ] is
hard
and i forget the percentage but
it was a massive third of the casualties
in way city were friendly fire
you know it's gonna happen square your
[ __ ] away fix what you can
and you move on um and that was
to me okay okay this is uh
i'm not the worst loser in the world
which i absolutely felt like
it's freaking horrible and then you know
uh a few months later mark lee is the
first seal killed in iraq
and you know i'm again just
heartbroken and and crushed
and admiral mcguire who i you know was
his aide for 13 months and
called me up you know and said hey
you got to get back out there yeah
you're doing the right thing and and
that kind of support from these senior
leaders at that time you know it's a
very similar
situation for me but um you know it's
real
easy too real easy
to pile on right to say
oh you had a blue on blue what the hell
is wrong with you
real easy to do that it's really though
you lost the guy what are you guys doing
real easy to take that approach and both
those guys
you know just just took the approach of
actually understanding what we were
going through
hey man there's we're we're getting in
firefights every single day here you
think we're going to make it through a
six-month deployment and not take any
casualties
like that's i don't even know i don't
even know why i would think that like
it's a crazy thought
but uh another good leadership lesson
and it's just you know
hey people are gonna have things happen
people are gonna make mistakes
things are gonna go wrong what are you
gonna do you're gonna you're gonna pile
on
especially somebody that's already
freaking tearing themselves up you're
gonna pile on and i had to do the same
thing you know with uh
with platoon commanders you know leif
babbin i mean he's he's
calling me up you know it's another he's
calling me up hey we just
you know guy got shot ryan job shot he's
hit bad i don't know if he's gonna live
the army's in a gunfight right now jocko
we need to go help him
and i'm like execute you know don't
didn't run it up the chain
the army's we're side by side with these
guys and he ends up losing mark
you know it's like are we gonna pile on
these guys are we gonna support they're
making a freaking hard decision they're
making the best possible decision they
can make at the time
and and that's what we have to do yep
yeah and your point about decision
making is a good one because
the nature of combat and to some degree
the nature even
prior to combat and training you see it
but more so in combat because to your
point
you're having to make hard decisions all
day long
you're just not going to get all those
decisions right when i when i became the
chancellor of the university of texas
system
uh i'm in charge of 14 institutions very
large institutions university texas at
austin and the anderson cancer clinic
and and i've often said you know in the
states today some of the hardest jobs in
the world are being the presidents of
institutions like that
because they've got students they've got
faculty they've got donors they've got
you know
all these sorts of things but every once
in a while there were people outside the
system that
well why did the president make that
decision why would he do something like
that why would she do that
and i'd have to say you know they make a
thousand decisions a day
999 of them you don't see because they
were good decisions and now you're going
to
get on them because they made one bad
decision uh
i i i got this you you thank you very
much for your input but
you know and i would tell the presidents
look i've got it i haven't been the
president
of university before but i've been in
charge of things
it's okay do the best you can you're
going to make mistakes i got your back
and but you know if you make a serious
mistake i'm also going to hold you
accountable
um yeah and if you if you're a repeat
offender right that means you're
probably not capable of doing the job
and we're gonna fire you and that's the
way it works
so you you end up retiring after 37
years
um uh i guess there was nowhere really
else for you to go
it worked the career worked out okay
yeah and
and then you you'd given that
commencement speech
which is i guess it's i have to check
with echo charles my my kind of
uh what is it pop culture guy yes was is
it safe to say that's a
a a viral speech viral okay
so might be even iconic oh iconic you
give the iconic make your bed speech
um did you know you're at what point did
you figure out you're gonna be the
chancellor there
yeah so they had approached me in april
about the job
um and uh and frankly initially
i said i wasn't interested i mean i was
coming off you know 37 years
i was really kind of ready for a break
and and i knew being the chancellor was
another
you know stepping into a you know 365 to
a year sort of job
um but i mean my wife and i would talk
about it and she said okay look
if you could do anything else because i
got asked to be ceos of this and that
if you could do anything else what would
you rather do and i thought
yeah i don't know this actually sounds
like a pretty good gig so i'm i've got
to have a
you know i'm going to have great
students that kind of like my troops uh
i'm going to have a football team and a
baseball team and a basketball team and
and i'll get to travel around i mean it
was essentially the same sort of
leadership
dynamics of being in the socom commander
the jsoc commander i mean again
you had faculty and students and issues
you had to deal with and i had
subordinate commanders and so it turned
out to be a great job but that was in
april
um and then i give the speech
in may um but it wasn't until
so the speech uh to your point i mean it
it gets a lot of traction and then uh
and it was about june i i decided you
know i think this is going to be a good
good job for me so we agreed to do it
and i think sometime in july they
kind of anointed me and then i took over
in january
you uh you like brushed over the fact
earlier that you got diagnosed with
cancer and
you know uh and in the book you talk
about kind of what that or one of the
books you talk about what that
experience was like and
and it it seemed like it was something
that you could kind of uh suppress for a
while
but it ended up what in 2017 kind of
catching up with you a bit
yeah it did so uh chronic lymphocytic
leukemia leukemia i mean the good news
is it's a chronic cancer so it is
manageable to a degree but
you know for years prior to 2010
every time i'd get a physical the
doctors would say well you know you're
anemic
i would say yeah well i'm sorry about
that and you know
i got a job dude what do i do and they
say well take eat more
protein take these iron tablets or
something right
and and then uh in 2010
uh a doctor diagnosed they did a
bone marrow biopsy and they came back
told me i had cll
and but i remember the doctors were more
concerned about the anemia they said
how do you get up in the morning i know
i get up i drink a couple of rippets uh
you know
energy drinks i go to work and um
because what was happening was my body
was storing the iron and the bone marrow
but it wasn't moving the iron
uh so long runs you know you just
weren't getting the oxygen
uh into the system but hey
sorry you got a job to do you know you
get up and do and so and then when i
became chancellor
i could tell that it was uh it was
starting to
to get more problematic um i was just
finding days i had trouble getting up
off the couch
you know and but again you have a job to
do so you
you get up and you go do it and you
power through it uh
finally in 2017 it just kind of perfect
storm i'd had a little bit of a virus
um the anemia was at its peak and uh
and my doctor who had diagnosed me in
2010 great guy named michael keating
who really kind of i talk about it in
the hero code
you know you go in there you're scared
you know thinking that you know my
career is over maybe my life's uh
over uh in the not too distant future
and he said hey
don't you worry about it we got this
you're going to be fine you
and of course first question i ask is
can i go back to afghanistan
my wife was like really that's your
first question uh
but uh so you know i was able to kind of
continue on but finally in 2017 it
caught up
i got some uh some therapy at md
anderson um
they pumped me full of chemicals and and
i mean a month later all my numbers were
good and i've been
you know knock on wood been feeling good
ever since then so
when'd you retire from the chancellor
job uh 2018
summer of 2018. and uh when did c
stories come out
all right i'll check yeah better check
uh sure
2019 maybe so also it's after you
retired
after our time yeah okay that was uh so
make your bed was the first one and that
was i think when i was still the
chancellor
yeah c stories was maybe 2019 and then
hero code just came out and so hero code
the latest one
before we close out uh what what brought
about the hero code
you know i think it really kind of came
back to make your bed i mean
i'm always just like you are joking you
know people are always asking me you
know
uh you know kind of give us more lessons
that sort of thing but but people were
asking me okay
tell me who your heroes are um and and
the hero code
it's not about me i mean it's through my
eyes but it's about people that i met or
encountered along the way
and it is about the qualities that they
had
um and i actually when i first started
it
um i thought you know what is a hero i
mean
we kind of intuitively know what a hero
is but i pulled up the textbook
definition
and it was actually pretty good the
textbook definition says a hero is
someone we admire
for their noble qualities and i like
this idea of their
noble qualities doesn't mean they're
perfect but they have noble qualities
certainly
at a point in time when when they need
them so the first story is about courage
and winston churchill said something
like
you know courage is the most important
of all qualities because it guarantees
all the rest
so you know you're not going to have
anything else unless you first have
courage and and the first story is about
ashley white who was
unfortunately killed in afghanistan and
her remarkable courage but i go through
the book with these
these stories of these people that i
think had the right qualities the
courage and humility and sacrifice and
perseverance and
in this sense of duty and you read a
little bit uh on the sense of humor
uh i mean frankly and i tell the story
about
being at udt11 but of course i saw that
sense of humor
in the hospitals and this is when it
really resonated with me back to the
the infantryman who said you know you
should have seen the other guy i mean
how many times did i
did i give some guy you know the kind of
good-natured banner you say man you look
like [ __ ]
that was always the standard comeback
you should see the other guy
uh and of course that was their way of
saying hey i may have lost an arm or a
leg
but they haven't beat me i can still
laugh about this and so you know and
then the last one is on forgiveness
and you talk about you know what
missions went south well this is one
that went really south on us
uh and it was a uh we were going after a
bad guy
in gardez uh had some soldiers on target
we thought the bad guy was in the
compound guys got up on the
on the walls sniper's looking down in
somebody comes out with an ak-47
he gets shot another guy in a doorway
picks up an ak-47
the the soldier automatic weapon
shoots him but in shooting him rounds go
through him
and unbeknownst killed a number of women
on the other side
and so when the action dies down they
get on target
uh they can't figure out why the the
women by the time we get in there
they are bound and and so frankly
initially we thought maybe it was honor
killing
but of course we didn't uh it sounds
crazy but we just didn't understand at
the time that
you know they bound them up so that they
the jaws didn't open and other things
and
so it took us a while to really
understand what's going on but then what
we realized as we did the investigation
was
a one the two guys with the ak-47s
turned out to be
afghan policemen and the women were
innocent bystanders
uh that we had unfortunately killed i
mean it was the war of all my time it
was the worst
you know kind of uh civilian casualty
incident
um that i'd seen and we'd had some bad
ones but none quite as bad as that
and i realized hey at the end of the day
i mean it's back on me
and so i went down to apologize to the
father
and i remember i linked up with some
afghan soldiers and and one other army
guy
and we went into this town in gardez and
of course there are hundreds of
angry afghans um
but you got an obligation you know so i
i sat down in this uh
kind of city hall for lack of a better
term with about 200 afghans seated there
and
and and i apologize to the father and i
remember before i did it i had talked to
my afghan
counterpart general saleem
and i said what do i say to this guy
i mean we killed his sons and a daughter
what do you say to a guy like that
and saleem looked at me and he kind of
cocked his head and he said oh he will
forgive you
i said so i don't know he goes oh no he
will he will forgive you
and i said well with all due respect
slain and he said he's a good muslim he
will forgive you
and he said look he said the thing about
forgiveness
is it not only relieves your burden
it will relieve his burden as well it
will take away his anger
and it will if he forgives you and i
thought man that that's
that's a stretch but i got there and sat
down with the father and i apologized to
him and
and i could see the look in his eye and
and they forgave me
and this idea of forgiveness
particularly today
you know it seems like everybody today
gets easily offended
um you know everybody gets slighted and
they want to hold on to that
anger they don't want to forgive people
for whatever that slight was
because the anger empowers them to be
mad
it empowers them to fight back and they
feel like if they let that anger go if
they forgive that individual
then they don't get to be the person
that holds the power
and i think that's just absolutely the
wrong way to approach it and i mean
the whole thing about forgiveness i tell
the story about there about the white
supremacist dylan roof that killed all
the people at the
the baptist church and the families went
up
one by one and said i forgive you i
forgive you and the point was
they were not gonna they were not gonna
hold on to that anger they were not
gonna kind of bear that burden
um so today as we look at society and we
we wonder
why everybody gets so offended i mean i
i would offer
uh take the opportunity to to try to
forgive the people that
offend you i mean some of them are big
offenses some of them are little ones
but i think as a society we can we can
do a little better than
and every single slide every single you
know
misstep somebody takes you don't have to
hold on to that anger you don't have to
fight back
you can forgive people oh it takes a lot
more strength to forgive someone than it
does to hold a grudge
it absolutely does i i often worry to
worry um because you know sometimes we
have whole
sections of society or countries or
peoples
that that have a grudge and
you know i i look at his two parts like
you need
one one side needs to say i'm sorry and
the other side needs to forgive
and it's very difficult to get two human
beings just just two human beings to do
that
and when you have you know a collective
lot of grievances from two different
opposing sides
we have a hard time making that progress
um that's the latest book the hero code
and as you as you and i were talking as
we as we started off
i i've written these kids books and uh
the kids books have a code the warrior
kid code and
i mean it's just the the similarities
are are awesome
it's awesome to see uh i know you didn't
read this but
but you know uh you know it talks about
humility and staying calm and treating
people with respect and trying to help
and protect people and
it's just these are the things that that
we need to do
and um yeah i appreciate the fact that
you you put this
this latest book out to to give people a
little guidance a little something to
strive for
uh with that it's only been
about four hours um
echo you got anything oddly no i don't
i think we covered it she usually throws
a curveball question at the end so
you're getting off easy
anything else before we close out yeah
uh
i want to thank you jaco um you know you
have
represented the community with
such dignity such honor i love what
you're doing
i love what you're doing with the
podcast i love what you're doing with
your life i love how you are engaging
with
the community around you um you know it
is important for us particularly at this
time you know the
the community has had its ups and downs
we're we're in a little bit of a trough
now
uh but we need great folks like you to
continue to
be the sort of representatives uh
that people can look up to uh and so
frankly i want to take time to thank you
for
the great work you've done the great
example you have set for
you know not just the the new young kids
that are going to be
sealed someday but frankly for everybody
you come in contact with
uh that's that's incredibly valuable
nowadays
so thanks well i i certainly appreciate
that i can i can guarantee you that um
there's there's the only reason i'm here
um is because what the community gave to
me and and the people that i was able to
follow
and emulate and it's just um
it's an honor to be sitting here talking
to you and
thanks for coming on today my pleasure
and and more important
thank you for your service to to the
navy to special operations
and first and foremost to our to our
great nation and then
somewhat selfishly um thank you for what
you did to the
for the teams thank you for leading me
and
and and my fellow frogmen and for
setting an example
that will forever guide our conduct
our character and our ethos it was my
honor thanks
and with that admiral mcraven has left
the building
so echo yes you were
you had no questions which is kind of
surprising it was crazy
did you start connecting the dots on who
was in the room
yeah more so the thing is already new
and
uh well one it depends on what you mean
by new
right but yeah i knew and i heard and
you know i am familiar
familiar with admiral mcrave okay so you
had you had connected the dots oh yeah
but not all of them though okay
and it's crazy to just hear them all
like the saddam hussein one i didn't
connect those dots before
um the captain phillips one i did not
know either
but but so you'd connected one out yeah
one dot
for as far as as far as you know some of
the some of the most important
special operations so awesome uh to have
him on here
and to be able to hear some of those
stories
and thoughts so
admiral craven thank you so much for
coming on
and what does this mean for us well
means we can do a little bit more
it means we can certainly we have work
to do
the work that we have to do starts with
us
in order to get better in order to move
in the right direction echo charles yes
sir
he said something he said something that
i i feel like i'm going to kind of take
this with him well
a lot of things obviously but one that
really stood out is and he said it twice
maybe three times where he's like my job
is to put you
set you up for success right put you in
a position where you can succeed
right that was his deal it's like man
that's a good way to put it right there
because you know how you always talk
about hey don't micromanage don't you
know you want to let your team lead you
know
how you put it and it's like yeah if you
because you can apply that to yourself
as well like bro set yourself up for
some success man sounds like a good plan
you know go learn some stuff yeah go
[ __ ] out 100 that's a great analogy and
i thought you were going to say
when he was talking about the guys like
hey sir you got nothing to prove
he says no you're wrong actually you've
got something to prove every day
and it's interesting something i used to
talk about to the young seal officers
is i would say you have nothing to prove
but everything to prove
because sometimes they think they got to
prove that they're in charge so they
start barking orders at people and
you know we're going to use my plan and
all that other stuff
and you don't have to prove that you're
in charge
we know you're in charge you're the
officer you're literally called the
officer in charge you don't need to
prove that
but you do need to prove
you did you you had a lot to prove yeah
it's like that always
struck me as a um like don't
like be aware of complacency or resting
on your laurels you know how like
you know someone who has the over stated
attitude of i don't have anything to
prove when it's like too much of that
right
little off balance of the dichotomy kind
of thing it's kind of like they did
something awesome
and then they sort of ride it out and
then they still think they should get
kind of the cred for it
like a hundred years later or whatever
and it's like hey like that's cool that
you did that but
recently you've been kind of doing
nothing kind of an added you know
so that that's what that always struck
me as where it's like you always have
something to prove
like don't be like oh yeah you should
like keep respecting me this much first
like one thing i did yesterday yeah well
you know 37 years for him in the seal
teams
in the in the military and again what's
i think is important is as he said
look there's so many people that did so
much have done so much work
so much work to to protect america and
everybody from you know obviously
the seal teams but just you know we
talked about the infantryman we talk
about everybody there's so much people
that work so hard
to protect freedom so
i feel like
you know you have a guy that's a
four-star admiral on
and of course you're gonna talk about
what his experiences were
and you know he's going to give you his
perspective but
you know i tried to point out in the
beginning he you know admiral mcraven
was always
connected to the guys on the front lines
and the people that are out there making
it happen so
awesome um
so we need to set ourselves up for
success is what you were saying before i
went on a little
uh yes sir what do we got how can we set
ourselves
up for success well big things and small
things and then a lot of us you know
we're not gonna be
admirals straight up i'm not gonna be
admiral
it's very unlikely we'll just say that
okay so
i'm gonna do maybe my small little part
to set myself up for success
okay just my small little part in your
world in my world exactly right so what
does that look like for me and i think
others too so this is
the good news about this this kind of
stuff is that it's achievable
by anyone just take a few little steps
set yourself up for success so what are
we doing
reading more we're working out more
keeping ourselves physically and
mentally capable that's what it is
an opportunity presents itself you want
to be physically and mentally capable or
you want to be physically
and mentally incapable that's the
question
is this a question for me we want to be
capable kind of rhetorical
kind of kind of obvious question so we
do that through working out we do that
through
reading paying attention and listening
that's a big one
a lot of us don't do that that much
anymore pay attention and listen
trust me kind of like you're not really
listening to me
you see what i'm saying so you see what
i'm saying anyway
on this path that we're doing all this
we do need supplementation so
good news we're gonna start with energy
drinks i'm calling it energy drinks it's
a new wave
of energy drinks do you think that these
energy drinks that we have created
are going to make all other energy
drinks obsolete
it we it has the potential to do that as
of right now hey this is kind of a new
thing technically
you know and but it seems like
it seems like that's a pretty obvious
course that seems like the people are
looking at
the old the dinosaurs we'll say they're
thinking oh this dinosaur
it it tastes okay and it gives me energy
for an hour
but then i ruined my health and i feel
like crap
yeah and then they look over at this can
of discipline go and they go oh this
makes me feel really good
and it's it's actually good for me yeah
this is
this is how uh this is how the old
energy drink dinosaurs are going to go
extinct
yes they're going extinct that looks
like the current tree
the freaking big comet just hit or
whatever it was what killed the
dinosaurs was it a volcano no i think it
was an asteroid
oh you know that's the current thing the
asteroid
the asteroid just hit the other energy
drinks in the form of jackal discipline
go oh yeah so they're going down just
anticipating fallout on that one
they're starving they're dying so yeah
so that's what's going on boom new
energy drink no stigma in this one
no no no sugar sweetened with monk fruit
no unhealthy preservatives no toxic
chemicals
no no preservatives whatsoever we it's
it's pasteurized boom
boom and it tastes good so boom this
thing is good for you straight out all
upside no downside
short-term and long-term benefits boom
strategic and tactical
discipline go there's there's also just
been going powder and capsule format
don't forget about that one also we got
stuff for you joints keep your joints in
the game
don't have to worry about doing that
anymore yesterday i did squats you did
squats when monday right
or something like this yeah i think it
was
so i always think about this where i'm
older than i was before
and so i incorporated the deep squats
right yeah
from your influence and i thank you for
it
and you think with a deep squat
especially when you go hard it's like
okay you know my knees because that's a
lot of times that's the that's
what you get like it's like oh yeah dude
so if you suggest deep squats
or something about all my knees or you
know and i get it it's true
so every time i think about this like
this joint stuff like my joints
i think about the squats got it by the
way yes
uh yesterday i started warming up doing
squats my brother came over
jade we start to talk you know you get
into conversations whatever the camera
and then not when you're squatting so
i'm
well you know in my i'm doing the
warm-ups
okay first one we get in this
conversation while i'm warming up
i do one preset i was explaining to
carrie i do one
preset okay dog okay hell yeah all day
and it's basically one set one it's like
a half working set it's like
the the weight that i'm gonna use for my
first working set i do that but not as
many reps as
so much so you know it's like a priming
kind of thing so i do that right boom
right at that point the conversation
goes deep
[Music]
so like we're just talking two hours
two and a half almost hours before my
first set but oh so now you so you're
saying there's a two-hour lag time
like time between my prime
i know so you prioritize next so in my
normal course of action
that kind of stuff happens this happened
before where it's like hey my
conversation came and hey sorry i
skipped the workout you know
the sun went down straight up it's dark
night time already i don't know 8 30
maybe
and it's like well you know i'm all cold
i've been sitting down talking for two
and a half hours
i'm not warm anymore and let's face it
but it's almost bedtime
why are people coming around your gym to
talk to you like that because my gym is
on the side of my house
outside yeah and you know i hey that's
that's a conversation for another time
for sure but it's significant
nonetheless so i go inside i'm like okay
cool i'll do the squats tomorrow
whatever
all good so i go inside i take off my
shoes and i'm like drink some water or
whatever and jade's leaving in the
friend they're leaving him like
i was like no man no no no it's not
gonna get me this time
conversation no conversation i go back
out finish the whole squat actually i
added one more set too like it by the
way
there you go the world right now
collectively is celebrating your
perspective
yeah oh yeah so might i add
joint warfare i was not worried about my
joints any at any moment yeah
my knee joints in this particular mouth
actually
i know where i got to curve that little
bit you got joint warfare on your
jawbone
anyway success all around joint warfare
super krill oil all day also we got some
immunity stuff this is important as well
you don't get sleep you know you were
kind of talking about not getting yeah i
had a couple
i had a messed up sleep schedule pass
not last night two nights before that
yeah i had one last night
anyway lack of sleep lack of this lack
of that can
kind of jam up your immune system don't
worry about that and stuff too that's
supplements for that
cold war vitamin d3
boom don't worry about your immune
system either joint immune system no
factor
right there um also milk
supplemental protein in the form of
desert that's uh that's some good stuff
as well a whole nother story but
good stuff nonetheless yeah you don't
you want let's face it you want ice
cream
ice cream has a lot of downside to it
yes it does you can
have milk all upside no downside
yeah upside legit upside
protein so to put that into perspective
and i just heard this i didn't even know
where i was listening to something
but and it reminded me some people eat
like a thing of ice cream
every single day it's like a thing you
know like oh at night after dinner for a
while
every single day every single day i
remember i was running
so much i was running so i think it was
uh i was out
i was out a team too and every day was
like
okay monday pt was like pt and the run
tuesday pt was of course end to run
wednesday was swim and a run
thursday was pt and a run again and then
friday was a run
what kind of run the friday run which
admiral talked about was like a 10 mile
or 12 miler
sorry can't do 10 miles i would come
back from that i would just do my 20 rep
squat routine too
so i was eating ice cream with a total
abandon
yeah yeah so the the the
situation i was hearing about reminded
that remind
it reminded me of the concept that some
people don't do these crazy runs or
workouts or whatever
it's just part of their normal everyday
routine like hey let me just eat some
ice cream every single day yeah
some obvious detriment when you do that
kind of stuff
you drink though you so you replace the
ice cream with the mulk
you got the same front side yeah there
were front end payoff
yeah but a way different back end payoff
actually you get a back-end payoff
unlike the back-end of
price cost hey you can get this stuff
jack-o-fuel.com
if you if you subscribe to it it's free
shipping which is a legit
thing because right now there's let's
face it there's large
rather large extremely large companies
that are trying to lure you
into their little realm yeah by giving
you free shipping
and we understand that we got to compete
with them so if you subscribe
free shipping you can do double support
much appreciated also we got
originusa.com if you need a jiu jitsu
if you need jeans if you need boots if
you need a t-shirt
if you need a belt
you can get it all origin usa.com
the usa part is not some sort of thrown
on
branding no because the stuff is
freaking made in america 100
without compromise think about that yeah
we're talking about
fighting for america cool that's awesome
we love it guess what else we got to do
we got to support the economy here
because without the american economy
nothing else matters you don't have a
military unless you have a good
economy so support the american economy
stuff that's made
in america with raw materials
that were made or grown or produced in
america
that's what we're doing originusa.com
get it yep
it's true also uh jacqueline store
called jocko store this is where you can
get your discipline equals freedom
good get after it all this uh all the
all the
representative ideas of the path
on your apparel is where you can get it
um also we have
a subscription as well free shipping on
this one only in the usa though as of
right now
okay we're working on the international
scenario but only in the usa it's called
shirt locker
this is where you can get shirts with a
little bit different more creative
we'll see more fun designs for like a
better way of maybe putting in anyway
they're more interesting
you get one every month it's kind of
interesting because once i get a hold of
a couple designs it's gonna be not fun
it's gonna be dark
not fun it's gonna be more cool well
there you go
they're not they're cool right now but
they're light-hearted some of them
yes people seem to be enjoying them um
yeah so yeah free shipping on that one
and yeah every month is a good one check
it out
if you like it hey get that subscribe to
this podcast too wherever you listen to
podcast don't forget we also have jocko
unraveling podcast with my man dc
daryl cooper putting out word grounded
podcast we have the warrior kid podcast
we also have jocko underground.com
if you want to get a little additional
podcast scenario you can check that out
uh you have to subscribe to it it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month
what are we doing with that we're
creating a platform of our own
that if things go sideways we got a
contingency plan we'll meet you in the
underground
underground jockowunderground.com come
and check that out we have a youtube
channel
by the way and uh
we make videos we make videos we do
we have obviously you all know echo's
got some technical skills
that he can put to use he can do the
editing and some of that other sort of
sort of just technical skills and then
obviously i come in with the assistant
director
and i kind of created and the creative
side the creative element the vision
and the talent by the way you're the
talent you know
but i do appreciate your being able to
edit
properly so if you want to see echo's
edits
and my vision yeah check out
speaking of jocko's vision
and my lack of vision from time to time
psychological warfare is an album with
tracks of jocko telling you how to skip
not skip
not skip not skip okay workouts
if you're in the mood to skip a workout
like basically to achieve what i
achieved
last night let's say you don't have that
fortitude that day
don't worry giaco got you on this one
this goes for a lot of other weaknesses
as well so check that one out
psychological
warfare if you want a little a spot
psychological spot getting over the
hesitation check out flipside
flipsidecanvas.com dakota my my brother
he's making cool stuff to hang on your
wall
also made in america we got some books
you heard about some of them today
spec ops these are from these are from
admiral william
h mcraven we got spec ops
we got make your bed we got c stories
and we got the latest
the hero code those are available on our
website if you go to
jockopodcast.com and you click on books
from the podcast they'll all be there
that's also a way to support too by the
way
we've got final spin this is uh
my book that's coming out and you're
gonna want that first a dish
you're gonna want the first dish so
order that the right now the publisher
is like where are you
american you're not really a fiction
writer
and we don't know people are probably
not going to appreciate your work
they're more looking for
uh well you know that's what they're
saying so like okay we'll print
you know a limited number of copies
technically aren't you a fictional
writer because i've written a bunch of
fiction kids books yeah you are correct
i made that point as well and then they
said that thank you very much
right got it so look the book comes out
they're we got to let them know at least
to print enough
so if you want to pre-order that one and
get that first a dish
go ahead and make that happen um so
that's final spin
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocol
which also yeah that's another code i
forgot to mention that one today yeah
uh the code the evaluation protocol this
one was freedom field manual
way of the warrior kid one two three and
four mike in the dragons about face by
hackworth
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
the leadership which i wrote with my
brother leif babin
lake fabin and i also have a leadership
consultancy and we solve problems
through leadership go to
ashlandfront.com
if you need us to come and help you in
your organization
we have we have extreme ownership
academy
online leadership training get to the
leadership gym
get to the hey you don't go to a gym one
time work out
and then you're good no you got to stay
healthy you got to maintain that
strength
so go to extremeownership.com
join our online we're doing by the way
you got questions come and ask me the
question i will be
on a zoom call literally ask
answering your question
come and check it out we have a live
event called the muster
next one up is phoenix
august 17th and 18th and then las vegas
october 28th and 29th check
extremeownership.com
for that as well all those are sold out
by the way and this one will too
these will too we have a couple other
events you can check out battlefield we
go battlefield walks we have ftx
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star family check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization
helps out our warriors if you want to
donate or you want to get involved
go to america's mightywarriors.org and
if you want
look if you want more of my over
elaborated estimations or you need
more of echo's disoriented discourse
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on instagram which echo only
refers to as the gram and on facebook
echoes that ecwid charles
and i am at jocko willink and thanks
once again
to admiral mcraven for
for everything too much to sum up
but thanks to all the soldiers sailors
airmen and marines
who have been on the battlefield
well for hundreds of years and who allow
america and freedom and democracy to
exist
and the same goes to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service and all first
responders
thank you for your protection here at
home
and everyone else out there you know i
didn't quite get into it
to this book the hero code
and admiral mcraven gives some
guidance on how a hero should live
but another thing that he indicates
is that you are the hero
we need it's you
go out there and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out